salut tout le monde si vous voulez louer
le studio sf pour faire votre propre
podcasts ou pour objet d la qualité de
votre podcast c'est possible écrivez
nous à sans filtre podcast at gmail.com
vous venez ici le service et tout
compris vous avez la vidéo vous avez le
son qu'on vous donne suite après votre
enregistrement
yann nicol qui va être là pour vous
servez pour vous accompagner dans cette
aventure
le studio sf on s'assure que la qualité
était petit mal à tous les niveaux et
puis pour ramener votre projet au niveau
c'est vraiment la bonne chose à faire
alors écrivez nous t'avons plaisir de
vous recevoir ici une production du f
[Musique]
bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut que nos invités
date titre super âge quand on est avec
moi d'une plante
cette semaine c'est notre 100e épisode
on a décidé de faire un peu différemment
et puis qu'est ce qu'on a fait de bien à
fond et donc d'un petit peu pompette à
l'heure actuelle revient sur les pas de
40 dans le fond là on a invité nicole
qui vous avez entendu parler souvent
mais que vous avez peut-être jamais vu
puis alexis qui est celui dans notre
équipe qui sait que des réseaux sociaux
puis on a jasé pendant deux heures deux
ans et demi pratiquement on a répondu à
vos questions que nous avons posées sur
instagram despars bonnes questions
parfois plus sérieuse parfois plus
délicat parfois plus grivoise mme et
plus plus alarmant c'est vers la fin
plus grivois
ce sera mes skis pays pauvres à la faim
de suite faux faux tout le processus
baxter a mal phone 7 comme le droit de
partir pour la 200e anniversaire et
anniversaire centièmes
on est avancé un petit pull qui a on
vous remercie vraiment d'être là parce
que si on fait 100 épisodes c'est parce
qu'il ya un public sont à zéro écoute
surtout nos podcasts
on aurait peut-être abandonné hulot dans
le fond des jo tai tak merci vraiment
d'être laide et continuer de nous
écouter de nous suivre ça nous fait
vraiment plaisir c'est un immense
bonheur et privilège de faire ce pas
casques bleus on adore ce qui est merci
au jury disant pas de casse mais je le
dis aussi merci à tous les invités qui
sont venus ce podcast qui ont pris de
leur temps pour pour venir ici pour
janvier aux hôtes puis s'est pas cassé
un succès c'est beaucoup grâce à eux
fait que sinon qu'est-ce qu'on ajoute le
chantre c'est le best
merci gagnant vous m
j'espère que vous allez apprécier cette
conversation beaucoup plus ludique qui
avec l ordinaire est fait que bon bac s
allait coûter cher
[Musique]
wright oye spécial sa 100ème épisode qui
s'adonne aussi à être pas mal le 2-1
presque deux ans l'épisode prochain oui
exact exact pis pour l'occasion on
voulait mettre nos boys en valeur merci
parce que en plus le tir aujourd'hui
j'ai posé des questions des questions ya
du monde qui écrivait on veut voir
nicole sic illégal qui vous travaillez
lalanne a taclé vous inspire le nicole
ici une icône nationale que vous
entendez parler mais qui est toujours
caché derrière la caméra
bref comme georges légende un mythe
lille - personnes 6 existe vraiment
québec si one radio le mystère est ce
que tu es vraiment le vrai michael
nichols et qui flippe les calmes en ce
moment à ce que c'est nicole que des
cannes c'était juste un plan sur deux
pour nico c'est tout réalise ça fait
partie du gang a fait ça et le masque
puis on à alexis ici lacam peut aller le
factuel leur chemin
tu peux approcher ton mike de toi alexis
c'est lui que vous voyez jamais mais
c'est lui derrière la page ferme sans
fil podcast c'est le grand manitou des
réseaux sociaux
pis si ça fasse vous dit quelque chose
parce qu'il est déjà vu dans votre
décision d'aller plaider que nous
soutenaient ce point à baho dès
maintenant de voyage à 12 fois par jour
et encore et encore dans toutes les
têtes l'économat chaque fois je vous
reconnais tes l'habitude squat de bord
avec potes pour chaque côté c'était pour
tout le monde bref est qu'on a décidé de
célébrer ce
puis quand j'entends tôt il ya quelques
épisodes qui sont des épisodes hors
catégorie qu'on n'a pas calculé dans le
conte c'est le 100e épisode mais c'est
probablement à peu près la 104e semaine
acquise en quatre ans on connaît ça fait
un peu plus que d'eux mêmes
ça fait un peu plus qu'un an je pense
que j'ai commencé le premier pas de
casque et j'ai fait avec alexandre
champagne qui est sorti en juin l'année
passée ouais c'est ça mettait pas
longtemps après c'était les jeux je
faisais les best-of des
un hameçon mouais ah ouais bah c'est ce
que ça fait pas mal de temps là quelques
quelques jours près équilibrées on n'est
pas trop en faire deux heures ça va
juste juste à ce que j'aime c'est juste
un pur ballon même nom mais pourrait
comme job mais personnellement j'ai
appris plus un inquiet quand 20 ans
d'études
mais ce soit mais toi en plus c'est que
tu écoutes tellement en plus d'apprendre
comme sur la job techniques et tous
étaient coûtent tellement de podcasts ne
bossait sur beaucoup de choses par le
bien les invités du monde pas si tpiy je
disais je pense que je faisais la pub
pour la location du studio le doute
était sans aucun doute la personne au
québec et compte le plus de podiums
salée pendant un an et demi c'est sûr
que oui c'est sûr que c'est une dizaine
d'après moi par semaine c'est du stock
un tas d'armes à ces mêmes s'étend au
jim des coûts de la musique partita
n'écoutez pas de casser c'est un métier
à quel point c'est complètement une
scène comme job dans le fond le tiche
payer à écouter des podcasts dans le
fond c'est sûr qu'il est content que tu
aimes ton travail parce que les nicole
mais alexis aussi les deux vous fait de
l'excellent travail
on ira tombé sur deux perles lepers à
blaye non mais c'est vrai c'est qu'on
peut lui faire confiance on sait que le
job là depuis toujours bien fait alors
les élections s'inquiète jamais le quai
sur les post réseaux sociaux tout le
temps ça à gauche
merci nice mais merci puis c'est moi
personnellement aussi je trouve ça
vraiment cool de participer à de
participer activement au développement
de
dans un art c'est la patte cassée c'est
quand même récent relative
ça fait pas cent au québec entre eux
trois ces bâtisses nous écoute ça fait
longtemps mais c'est moi je pense
quelqu'un vous arriver je pense que la
game a changé ou s'il est il ya plein
d'autres podcast qui ont participé aux
autres partis forment aussi toutes
sortes et daudet premier podcast avec
les en ado fait que cette entrée comme
moi vous êtes entré comme dans l'espèce
du web populaires comme d'une chute de m
puis je pense que sais je sur mettons
pour pour le podcast en général je pense
a fait beaucoup de votre podcast y est
pour beaucoup dû piqm viapresse a bâti
avec le studio
je pense que pauvre et propre est bien
loin et vous laisser c'est quand même
plaisir tellement d'autonomie tellement
d on est vraiment quand je prends
lextreyt et je suis libre à 100% vous
vérifierez d'après moi aussi j'apprends
beaucoup en écoutant le podcast mais ça
c'est vraiment une force que vous avez
les gueux d'être capable d'être autonome
c'est vraiment une autre on est quand
même en at-il le studio c'est une
affaire en eaux vives étions quand même
d'autres choses à gérer puis le fait qu'
on sait qu'il aime et on mois chez
quelqu'un comme de midi on sait que les
pauses moins de faits telle journée
taylor puis que ça vaille clean
on n'a même pas accouché à bord 90 l
église est un extrait où un autre apport
ces moments là j'ai aucune inquiétude
qui va sortir de quoi qu'on importe et
puis quand j'ai aucune inquiétude que
quand il ya quelqu'un qui a réservé le
studio que tout va être le temps comme
jamais je me dis ainsi que je confirme
nicole ici et bec avec la brosse et
juste des fois je t'écris cabine était
oui laure d'attitude parce que s'il ya
des choses à faire et d'une journée on a
l'esprit tranquille on peut faire nous
en faire une force
thiriez qui admettons dab d'engager
quelqu'un mais finalement de tout
comment faire de bach en fermant qui
compte peu de temps nous observons seul
but de gagner quand il ce temps puis on
engage vraiment beaucoup
grâce à vous des lônes on appris des
questions tombeau juste lancé des
questions et on va discuter en tables
rondes les gueux sur ces questions le
's&p' puis on a en somme tout pas un
mode festif et comment de la bière ce
n'est pas vous lever et aller chercher
d'autres facs
j'ai fait les poches aiderait donc j'ai
posé des questions sur instagram ce
matin guy règles qui eut tellement
cotation s'est beaucoup de questions qui
revenait beaucoup fait qui selon plus
lire on peut les traiter d'un enfant
note il est question vaut ne pas y
répondre
regarde c'est que là on va parler
pendant 35 minutes de la théorie des
couleurs qu'on a parlé avec a dit le
pleinement qui m'ont écrit par rapport à
ce jeu très loin à petit j'ai comme
exprimer un concept qui existe en
mathématiques était comme qu'est ce que
tout le monde perd souhaite peut-être
les couleurs une façon différente ne
sera jamais puis il ya plein de monde
qui m'ont écrit en dm sur mon compte
privé déjà et je pensais que j'étais le
seul ou la seule à avoir eu cette
réflexion le plus jeune michael était un
autre j'ai fait pose c'est vrai ce qui
rend une façon de maladie aucun moyen de
savoir si le rouge de ton star wars
l'idée 0 cela même pour tant pis pour
moi j'ai aucun moyen sauf que tous
conseillers des constructions sociales
d'agression en croire c'est pourquoi ces
quatre là sont bons pour que sa fille
que c'est chaud froid
d'autres ces concepts le peut-être que
ont saisi fait apprendre d'une ovation
je me rappelle dans ce podcast l'étude
ict porte avait pensé à ça
un prime à un moment donné tu mais j'ai
pensé à cette plainte soit aussi bon à
jouer tu attends ton corps l'esprit que
ma vague at on dit ouais c'est vraiment
mon genre de trucs robin est ce qu'on
verra une simulation tout cas sympa
ben moi je pensais pas possible si si il
en masse qui lui m'a dit c'est toujours
raison en pourcentage est descendu les
dernières années sim et on peut imaginer
qu'on est capable de faire un ordinateur
assez puissant pour faire une simulation
complètement réel tu mets ton heure de
temps infiniment puissant pileux dans
cette simulation en laye pour avoir une
infinité d'ordinateurs et qui font des
simulations avec 6,6 s est même possible
de le faire qui soit sûr qu'on est déjà
dans une situation parce qu'il révèle
bien plus d'univers six minutes que des
vrais univers mais aspar et nous autres
mets ton avec l'attak la technologie
camp où on est rendu en ce moment je
pense qu'on n'est pas si loin que ça
d'être d'être capable de petit lys est
une simulation mais de marde mettons
parce qu'après ça on est petit on n'est
pas si loin d'avoir des capacités
technologiques assez incroyable mais on
est quand l'ismans loin d'être capable
de créer un
un autre qui pensant par lui même ce que
dit il et toutes les clés toutes les
choses que nous on possède en tant
qu'être humain on est loin tabarnak de
ce type y mettons l'exemple des sims
c'est une simulation mais à quel point
est ce qu'un film c'est loin d'être
immérité qui évolue comme cela en dit
long et on s'est très légèrement
cette fois c'est pas un ordinateur c'est
un genre de des micros biodôme on fait
le tri c'est peut-être peut-être kitimat
temps nous autres on sait comment
comment la vie mettons ça fonctionne
c'est comment les les plans de pose
comment les êtres vivants nestea et tout
fait peut-être peut-être qu'on est
capable de reproduire ce scandale s est
fait main basse comme dans l'épisode des
simpson ne veut pas c'est l'épisode
d'halloween ou est ce qu'elle disait
jacques rey de la vie mais la vie elle
évolue vraiment rapidement puis genre
comme deux jours il ya aujourd'hui des
space ship qui parle de genre de son
petit bocal ccsa comité hockey la
question qui revenait le plus pur les
questions le classique le fakir voici
ses réponses on passera pas une heure là
dessus si les podcasts ou le plus marqué
c'est le meilleur éviter les podcasts
sens dans l'eau dans nos tops podcasts
et pis c'est vraiment à dubaï a pensé
que c'était un succès depuis le 1 t de
toute écoute et qu'il fait clair on est
on est toutes des personnes qu'ils ont
chois véhicule ou écouter l'entraîneur
la ligne des six mètres un peu mais je
sais déjà c'est comment on est très
basique commence du corps du oui mais
non c'est juste avant que je commence à
travailler pour vous puis pauvres est
juste que ce soit l'invité que je
découvre encore des interviews des son
shoot et les caves et avec là je
connaissais pas taxe qui connaissait
pour sa part l'exacte mais non tout en
podcast que ce soit l'invité comment ils
pensent qu'ils étaient surpris par vos
connaissances depuis le camp et
commençait à parler de biologie capote
est tué dans ses yeux moi mais sinon
aussi tous les podcasts avec jay du
genre ambitieux le je pensais plus comme
lui en tant que tel qui arrive tout avec
un espèce de vague de gentils garçons et
ces genres folk et tout le monde aime
visage apparaît évidemment
vous avez avec les vraiment easy à
izia tomber direct dans le vif du sujet
y a pas de vieux potes t il sa celui-ci
puis une minute après on est déjà en
train de parler d'eux comme comment et
comment aviez comment on voit ce que
c'est que les étiquettes sont extraits
le wake up the fuck je me trompe
non on n'est qu'en mai on est tombé non
c'est clair dit c'est sûr que tout les
podcasts des mondiaux qu'un autre qui on
parlait de gueuler un peu avant de
rentrer en ont un qui crypte on dirait
tranquillement dans mon appréciation
c'est parce qu'ils changent un peu plus
plus le temps avance et mais cela avec
joe roi je les ai même gelé vraiment
aimé juste par le joy arrive ici un peu
comme gilles et arrivent ici avec un
vrai bhl timone si tu parles plus juste
quelqu'un qui te réponds et mm c'est
juste un gars qui est supposé question
qui fait et m
j'ai vraiment le goal est ce que l'on
réfléchisse tisser chercher il a été
questionné tpiy j'ai vraiment ouvert
curieux des autres aussi puissent ainsi
se séparent casques bleus qui étaient en
fait pas des podcasts nous métier c'est
le fun qui les invitait aussi puis vous
les gothiques qui c'est vraiment une
chance puisque chacun amène son grain de
sel qui ont réfléchi ensemble qu'on se
questionne ensemble c'est tout d'abord
un bilan sera fait sur wii 10 ans dès
demain misant des vraiment s'intéresser
au monde c'est vraiment dur à expliquer
c'est quoi il ya comme un genre de c
le nommé cse c'est le charisme c'est dur
à définir c'est dur de voir c'est quoi
du charisme c'est pas seulement
quelqu'un qui qui parle en public c'est
la prestance mais du charisme c'est
quelque chose qui t'attire vers
quelqu'un papa de poche physiquement
mais qui t'attire intellectuellement
d'affaires acquis non j'ai envie de
graviter autour de cette personne là
dessus puis mojo samoans aussi seul et
c'est bien à plusieurs comme c'est moi
je ne sais pas tu rencontres tony comme
étant un tènement ben moi maintenant
massés sur le moment pas de casse
préféré je pensais de tous les temps
c'est avec beaucoup aussi nous jetaient
pas là non plus c'est d'aller on
attendait notre notre sommet avant que
vous avez vraiment qu'ils mais sinon
j'avais laura turconi les invités de
même qu'on reçoit que c'est si du monde
que tu dis aux autres dans la catégorie
gêne il tait son décor is joe d'esprit
et brillante du moins érudits au lit
fait partie de ces bonnes âmes et hop
une mouche un enfant de levier bernard
machine qui n'est pas avec lui j'ai
tripé d'arrêt cardio ses dents et hop
ils rentrent caussade un top ou six noms
récemment si on ne le fait
tim et on nous casse de webster direct
dans le mouvement après la mort de john
schultz
c'est ce test est puissant je trouve l
audi arrive avec avec toutes ses
connaissances historiques sujet très
savamment hauteur
lui c'est le cas sous en termes
d'apprentissage personnel culturel peu
importe je suis sorti de là comme une
vision différente de deux mondes au
complexe au sud c'est vrai d'arrivée et
hystérie aussi charisme ne tire sur moi
je n'ai pas rencontré le médecin quatre
ans au ça paraissait bt oui mais thil
l'espoir go dans gotti timide le tiki
parle t il pas trop forte somme est
tellement solide qui connaît tellement
son affaire de sifflet on était athée
accroché pendus à ses lèvres le
tiendrait au fait que c'est ceci d'un
topo si c'est sûr mais aussi et surtout
parce que ces dames en effet des bepa 2
cas justement qui niveau timing avec ce
qui se passe dans le monde plie sujet
c'était comme vraiment intense trouver
le type i might & stay cool cela est
extrêmement cool
alice qui est venu récemment qui une
fois king prose ou un podcast qui je
pensais vraiment pas que ça là les leurs
mais finalement c'était vraiment bon
c'était avec alice morel-michaud ravier
joseph politique pendant longtemps
en plus d'une journée quand on est trop
c'était le dernier
on a tourné trop les têtes brûlées mais
là les salariés vont sur une bière puis
on tombe on eu dans ma politique dans
ses idées au meilleur de la journée
tellement politisé et tellement informé
est tellement est vraiment hâte ses fils
une rapide si c'est ce qui c'est qui qui
reçoit alice morel michaud pour parler
de politique
pour ce ne serait pas à dire ça ne
serait pas du téléthon mais c'est certes
ici c'est la force d'un bon pack a su si
c'est qu'il ya pas d étayer ya pas d des
kids c'est y ait pas d
ce moment présent en fait la discussion
vaut où c'est que ça s'en veut puis da
titre arrête
ap je pense la deuxième question qui
revient le plus après nos meilleurs
invités par cas ceux ci une question à
laquelle qu'on répond de repos parce que
c'est chimie on en savait trop posé
fanion vaut moins d'adressé si c'est
quoi vos pires pas de quatre mois c'est
quoi le monde maintenant tout ça c'est
quoi genre les pattes casque vous étiez
le plus à coeur de kebede malaise ce
petit jeu peut tout genre 95% des
podcasts si on chante dans les lieux
puis ce texte est malade d'hazard temps
sa clique - ou temps en temps ça peut
arriver mais c'est vraiment rare puis
quand que ça arrive on laisser aux gens
on va laisser aux gens c'est le deviner
le manque quelqu'un qui écoute
activement thénot pas de calais exauçant
rencontre même si je pense que c'est un
tout et on n'a pas eu aucun podcast qui
çà et là mais ses soutiens qui tu es tu
es capable d'entendre la différence
entre un podcast de genzyme qu'on tombe
dans une zone depuis un port casque et
un petit peu moins fluide c'est qu'on
est moins en proximité avec l'invité
mettons donc on est moins à l'aise avec
le sujet qui est traitée aussi vous
sinon tafer des fois t'es des fois on
est préparé qui se ment des fois notre
vie et fait qu'on l'est un peu moins des
2 cv
on est un petit peu moins je pense que
de base de kant invités arrivés encore
le jeu peut tout le temps le mais qu'on
écoute le podcast est là tout de suite
on sait si lille iii les oublis comme je
demandais ou pas mais y en eu tu vois
tout de suite que je trouve que les
vingt premières minutes ont comme
déterminante parce que moi pendant ces
vingt premières minutes l'histoire il
parle pas trop répondait petite question
après des fois ça découle maintenant
souvent bien peu souvent pas du tout si
on émet des fois ça arrive que n'ont pu
mettre la main à moi je perçois façon
exacte c'est ce que des fois des fois tu
nous on prend plus de place un peu quand
ça arrive des fois on se le faire
reprocher sur youtube c'est quand même
les gars vous parlez beaucoup c'est que
moi mais quand qu'on parle beaucoup
c'est parce que l'incident
pas tant que ça il faut quand même
essayer d'être comblé on se dise pas une
entrevue confort de pose des questions
préparées fonctions les pri avons une
discussion on va l'avoir
c'est ça te dérange vraiment le jeu est
un peu beach il mais ça dérange vraiment
quand on parle aux péris écoute notre
chaîne
podcast ces conteneurs pascal arrêter de
parler parler de lui il ya un a quitté
je vois des camps dans des fossés et on
vient ici pour l'inviter vas-tu ainsi
que pour l'invité était l'invité écoutez
notre vidéo l'invité peut-être une
entrevue qui est fait avec urbania je
sais pas quoi ce qui laisse une entrevue
construit exactement podcast pour un
autre nom exact il faut comprendre ce
qu'est du monde qu'ils ont demandée par
exemple si elle n'est pas de casque on
le fait qu'on ait décidé de pas forcé
parce qu'on trouvait c'est trop la marne
se sait jamais non si jamais toutes les
pâtes gascon a tourné on les associe on
s'est demandé beaucoup comme un conte se
prépare puisque c'est drôle mais si on
se prépare c'est c'est vraiment rare
qu'on s'en parle avant sa part jamais
c'est ok on va ça parle jamais on reçoit
quelqu'un mais ton et qui fait date
lorsque quelqu'un à qui et c'est beau
puis on arrive dans pileux avant très
vite arrive de ph
on parle de tout et de rien même pas de
ce qu'on va parler puis on s'assoit puis
on commence puis péage de saint barth et
des affaires pense ce qu'il veut parler
mou de montbard puis on parle puis on se
fait assez confiance pour savoir que que
ça va marcher ou pas à temps et les
invités qui est sion le 6 mai ton qui on
les invite pour parler d'un sujet fait
que ça arrive quelques invités on you
you en somme un courrier où il est
invité qui s'est maintenant le
pharmacien justement lutter x wing à son
affaire
ses tacles et kaka higuain qui vient
distingue aussi qui peut parler d'un
million d'affaires takhir aider les
gauchos pro je proposerai peut-être
qu'on parle de s'associer avec lui lui a
remis le prix
mais jean philippe bien fait lui aussi
des sommets sinon le sait vraiment or
même avec l'invité et puis entre nous
qu'on sent par l'avant mais témoins je
peux parler pour moi je fais jamais
recherche n'est qu'un comité d'examen
qu'un tour soit la liste d'olivier
l'étoile lewy des recherches moi je me
prends des notes
même des fois le mettons vraiment pas
tous les podcasts mais des podcasts qui
mettons je voudrais plus assurer le des
fois j'ai juste à m'en charpy je parle
tout seul je ne fais pas de casse
non mais pas je le ferai pas de casse
mais mettons je me rends compte que si
mettant des trucs que tu réfléchis
m'étais jamais verbalisé la première
fois qu'ils voient le dire ça se peut
que ça surtout pas la meilleure façon
c'est fakty des fois il ya des trucs
mettons des sujets que je sais qu'on va
parler tant que je me me prendre je mène
être troqués de sujets avec peut-être
3,4 infos que j'ai checké plus je le dis
à voix haute c'est juste pour comme la
voie à voir passer dans une fois pour
que la prochaine fois que je le dis
c'est comme si des jeux un peu plus
forme et la matière ma pensée je pense
que je l'avais déjà dit sur un podcast
mais moi je fais un peu l'équivalent des
deux hommes est maintenant on cherche à
tout le monde en parle mais en même
temps je réfléchis c'est lui qui assure
des patients congrès oui j'arrive flèche
par la guiche par la guilde de sujets
qu'ils puissent être même pas mettant
juste pour le podcast mais même cas que
je t'ai qu'elle chutait au cégep et à
l'université quand j'étudiais en
littérature c'est que des fois les
examens littérature c'est pas déçu oui
ou non lundi c'est vraiment laid longue
réponse puisqu'elle fait d'assimiler une
matière
j'étais à tout le monde en parle puis
jean par les gens parlaient agliotti la
matière si je faisais du choc le souvent
le 10e anniversaire et puis tu parles
haggui a tout le temps à mon short dont
et drôle
la question qui titille la pelloche des
pythies ça travaille sa rhétorique aussi
plus élevé mais je pense aussi au point
que je voulais dire c'est qu'on met tout
quatre fois la timone apparaître des
gaules mieux préparé
ce serait même davantage de l'aviation
ça fait des décennies tard il attend de
ce qui me rappelle mon dieu c'est bien
se passer comme j'ai toujours rêvé mais
un prof est ce que ta prof à
l'université mandat ph pourquoi tu
commences et on essaie par sa
liquidation
merci qui ce que je regrette c'est qu'on
se prépare aussi de façon différente si
on aborde les podcasts de façon
différente je pense que ça fait qu'on se
complète bien souvent plus puristes l
accès sur l'imputé plutôt souvent des
idées des idées ou des trucs que tu veux
penser sur l'invité des concepts que tu
veux essayer de discuter avec l'invité
je pense que ça fait qu'il ya une
dynamique s'installe qui est pas là qui
est pas la même on n'amène pas le même
la même chose dans une conversation
s'est fait que je pense que ça contribue
aussi au fait que on peut aller si
l'invité plus préparés a plus envie de
parler de sujets précis au palais rameau
délais mais c'est aussi on va être plus
large si on peut on peut partir de
l'autre gbagbo s'il fait que tu des
invités maintenant que vous êtes comme
un peu stressé mettons à 20 qui avant de
recevoir nice tarif on arrive
est-ce que depuis que vous êtes en
colocation vous parlez plus de la
préparation on peut pas vraiment mais ce
qu'on discute plus ensemble on parle on
discute et on n'est plus des
conversations ensemble paquet
directement mettons notre opinion sur la
vague de dénonciations et sûrement
beaucoup plus aiguisée que si j'ai
peut-être juste parce qu'on s'entend
constamment cette semaine leur mettons
le par exemple qu'on a reçue à l'itie
que les dénonciations sortie de dire mes
perches on était une semaine à faire que
ce check et ceux à 100 par les qui se
passe d'être sénat la nappe là on
appelle avec alice plomb continent par
les taxes et c'est ce qu'ils voient ils
ont discuté de plus puis temps en temps
on fait pour le studio pour le podcast à
l'as far difficulté qu'on en parle un
peu plus mais en même temps aussi un
vrai de la seule différence c'est qu'à
place de ce texte
c'est comme un têtu dispo ce pôle en
chine trois trésors
c'est comme la place de telles
techniques sur messenger également
mais je me souviens pas d'un faux j'ai
été vraiment stressé sûr je me souviens
au début le candidat chez ph le j'étais
stressée noir mais dans chaque fois
c'est fou un titi le deuxième podcast
qu'on a fait c'est à gabriel nadeau
dubois
puis quand gary rentrée ne le connaissez
pas tu le connaissais pas comme un
jardin genre de stress de kanaky
séquence politique si pauline ado pas au
sens de jugement de valeur qui que ce
soit mais c'est quand qu'il est une
personnalité politique que nous on a on
a milité aussi en 2012 un peu derrière
lui moitié fait que si comme on va
parler du sujet très sérieux pitt il
faut t il faut préparer il faut être bon
type il est stressé moi je me suis
justement le type est agitée comme au
deuxième étage pis s'ils ont des 30
équipes à l'article tu mènes avec jallet
laisse très enlevante les un petit
maintenant c'est lui justement pour
mettre en contraste avec la nouvelle la
dernière fois qu'on a reçues gave de
semaine s'est quant à elle salue même
genre on s'assoit on parle un peu
n'importe quoi avant on commence on
gamme l'été on se fout de chute avec gad
c'était juste une autre fois où je me
suis aussi la relation entre luc nous
qui échangent éthiques
comme je les côtoyer beaucoup plus
souvent que son parc à ce type tout le
métier que moi pour ma part je suis
vraiment plus anciens et gabla man et
j'essaie de poser une question est posée
pour ceux qui sont à l'écouté pas de
gastes en ce moment c'est la seule fois
que tu m'expliques est allé faire du
montage qui fait une cote parce que j'ai
appris comme j comme figé même pendant
un bon 5 secondes et cela s'est excusé
pilager ce qui m'a frappé au visage un
deuxième podcast maintenant j'écoute est
bien semaine c'est un pas de castor kaki
que ça fait longtemps qu fesses aux
états unis puis lui explique maintenant
il y avait beaucoup de coups de béquille
pour calmer tant il ya une phrase qui
tombe presque pas trop sur quoi report
mais il commence à parler en sachant pas
vers où sans vote
moi j'ai que j'ai réalisé que je fais
c'est quand même souvent des podcasts ou
est-ce que là ça tombe
à commencer son temps puis l'a jeté
comme pas prêt à ce qu'attend parce que
moi je pensais que l'invite allait
continuer ou qu'on allait rebondir
quelque chose d'autre que je vois qu'il
ya personne qui relance plus et comme ou
un métis qui vivent ce qui est vraiment
intéressant à ce club pendant ce temps
la c4 d'entamer notre mental chacun
c'est là je voulais aller puis comme
c'est super chouette puis c'est tout d
abord au début j'allais remarquer en
plus bas c'est sûr quand tu commences tu
effaces part c'est vraiment intéressant
ouais c'est le changement de certaines à
la presse qu on s'envole parce que on ne
peut ne pas de notre physique tu es fait
qu'un requin est un sujet qui tombe puis
j'ai pas envie qui s'appelle juste comme
point une autre et un autre paragraphe
ci-dessus tu sais comme faisons une
transition suspendu mampy quand tu es
dans conversations a pas pensé à ce que
tu veux dire après parce que c'est la
base une conversation tuer la plupart du
temps quand tu écoutes qui compare les
têtes en donne de très bons qu'est ce
que je dis après mais c'est pas vraiment
sur une conversation tu peux écouter
l'autre personne qui vous fait clair des
couteaux de personnes plutôt rien à dire
de plus ce type le ça finit plus faible
afin que n'étaient pas en train de
penser à prochaine affaire j'allais dire
faible en cinq secondes
mais si tu vois ce qu'on t'a conduit 2
des fois pour ceux qui tout seul d'être
plus tard est celui qui doit trouver la
prochaine affaire en plus maintenant
qu'un éviter que ça s'apprend et ça
prend des notes
au moins tu t'es fait avoir comme
société on tombe direct à rien tu peux
partir de quelques mois là on est deux
fait qu'on sait que ça arrive jamais si
jamais arrivé vraiment un moment où est
ce que c'est qu'un bon 3 secondes de
rien pantoute
ce quelqu'un qui veut
adamo débute en paca non mais maintenant
il parle et on a multiplié presque fini
puis le banc on parle de quoi l'eau j'ai
l'impression il a appris son métier en
faisant débuter vraiment moins j'aurai
habile mais en ce moment les imams en ce
moment tu vois quelqu'un qui commence à
manquer d'idées mais comment ces
questions du genre et séquences à être
lé mal est fait et adam wood y avait un
super pouvoir jouer capable de mettre
tout le monde sous vide jardins
quote-part des genres il va être capable
de mettre n'importe quoi suivi avec si
vous mettre la planète sous vide pour
casque s'autoprotègent tout le monde
soit figé dans l'univers jusqu'à gens
qui puissent enlever le shoegaze puisque
monde soit gamme comme si rien ne
s'était passé autres sait pas à quel
point il faut qu'ils soient gelés pour
tancer pour elle comme de toutes les
super pouvoirs c'est lui qui choisit
comme hank est bon prochaine question
s'il ya eu un dollar
comment que notre vie a changé en deux
en podcast
mais est-ce qu'on est fier du chemin de
ricoh du mois le podcast mais mettons je
veux commencer par là pas de cas je suis
allé plus attelage apprennent en passant
on commence explication plus générale je
gardais les questions plus qu'un outil
pour la fin ok soyez patients les amis
les clowns s'en vient pas plus le avec
la viande jeunes chinois bien c'est
parfait mais c'est moi mettons le
podcast c'est vraiment le
le projet sur lequel j'ai été le plus
assidu le toute ma vie mais ils peuvent
vous êtes tellement bon pé i fall c'est
selon c'est un par semaine qu'on s'est
dit au début on s'est dit on va en faire
un par semaine puis on a tout fait
tester des pieds et des mains et parfois
le pour être capable d'en faire un par
semaine puis crise on le fait même 2 1
200 épisodes plus que 100 épisodes à
avoir un podcast parfois quelques
semaines ouais moi même c'est le projet
avec le plus d'acides technique que j'ai
eus pis et comme de fait si ils disent
tout le temps on entend souvent tu veux
si tu veux que tu fasses de quoi qui
réussit faut que tu le fasses
fréquemment et puis continuer à le faire
contre la constance puis pour vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est ce que s'est passé
c'est parce que oui et et les vues
différents différencie selon l'invité
qu'on a mais somme toute on attend une
croissance qui est constant depuis ses
hommes c'est la constance non c'est
vraiment puis qui commet novion changé
moi mais moi c'est ici tout ce qu'on a
appris jeudi
c'est le nombre de sujets sur lesquels
maintenant j'ai des connaissances avec
les recherches graphiques des
discussions qu'on ne le nombre de sujets
shamash l'est sur lesquelles ma pensée a
vraiment changé comment que j'ai grandi
en tant qu'humain c'est énorme je pense
vraiment que je suis une meilleure
personne grève le 2 ème juste petit
justement titre home et on invite ont
parlé de jets ou joy white side monde
qui sont des des belles personnes qui
jouent dans la majorité dit mangini si
ce schéma là tout le monde glisse ce
sont des belles personnes c puis justice
par osmose on on peut exact mais oui ça
qu'ils ont vraiment non c'est qu'il a
tout offert ibles superstar substance
qui tu vas là haut dès cette année
la question mais oui c'est ça que c'est
si la question est ce que je veux aller
à od cette année j'ai le regret
d'annoncer que je n'ai même pas fait les
auditions mais je mentirais si je disais
que je les peaux j japon - pas je fais
tous comme ça je me suis dit prouverait
à ce moment ça va bien
j'aime ce que je fais pas besoin de rien
changé
j'ai pas besoin d'aller le pit se
faisaient la vie d un staff m
et tous le jeudi est ce que ça
m'intéresse tant que je sais pas ce que
j'ai pu pour cent d'ici là l'intérêt
métis l'an prochain les conditions sont
le piéger l'appel gérer cette année là
justement y avait comme un signe d'unité
comme une coupe de gens qui te font est
à vis des états vidéo le par à ce jour
là je te le fais tu subis georges amani
je me suis réveillée dès lundi parce que
je dois faire des super légers plus que
je fasse pour l'évier ou sur le paquet
les débats de 15 qui commande aux
délires de lait candia seront dix-sept
bac c'est sûr que j'aurais fait genre
hebdomadaire de 40 minutes à chaque à
chaque semaine ou est ce que c'est juste
moi ci a comme jaser de ce qui vient de
se passer à rodez - une poudre déjà dit
quelqu'un qui l'a déjà fait de caisse
que ace et possiblement réellement passé
à l'intérieur ça aurait été intéressant
bah je suis satisfait mais c'est sûr
mais j'y ai pensé en positif et ça c'est
sûr que je vais m'installer 30 minutes
au minimum 30 et 9 h par semaine à comme
analyser ce qui s'est passé
mais on s'entend qui est ici j'ai fait
audi c'est ce genre et gan israël et non
mais en fait j'ai aucune idée comment je
réagis dans ce contexte l'ue je veux
qu'ils perdent la bourse est une affaire
on est quand même dans un contexte comme
celui plus cartésiens dans mes relations
maintenant que quelques toiles toutes
les plus pauvres flamboyant mais tu
étais plus mais je quand même cartésien
aussi méthodes et ultime carte et digoin
on met la bosse et comme je pensais même
pas être cartésien ma vie je capable de
quand même bien géré et aisément gérer
mes émotions puis tu mets ton quand je
bois de l'alcool je pense tu sais tu
m'as vu je pense forme avec ma grain
quand je bois le titre est capable de de
gérer mes émotions c'est moi vu
d'ailleurs tu le sais tu m'as vu
cash tech olympique m'a fait des avances
cas si vous voulez le henkell co manette
voilà un métier fait avec moi j'ai ça
puisse escapade vraiment bien géré mes
émotions
idem lui est plus sûr l'émotion tout
dans ces moments là puis à od même site
c'est même moi je pensais que tu es bon
là-dedans leuthard est dans une
situation comme ça mais même moi qui
pensais que j'étais bon là dedans tu
réalises que tabarnak man c'est plutôt
que tu penses dans un contexte de monde
mais ça favorise pas aussi maintenant de
finale non mais je vous dit d'être plus
sur tf1 probablement être une
personnalité extravertie justement
coloré je suis chaud de tva fin ce qui
me serait plage pas en plus pour ta
santé mentale
piti piti le faire des moves si je te
marrer les gens quel contexte plutôt
faire des moves comme le maroilles que
tu ferais pas david dans un endroit
paradisiaque même c'est pas ton coup de
coeur numéro un ça se peut que tu as
envie de frenchy la fée qui est là parce
que tout et c'est tout est placé pour
que tu as envie de faire ça avec nos
cités s'étaient tues contrôle pas cette
pulsion le fasse quelque chose que tu
vas pas regretté c'est une question
qu'on rentre tranquillement d'aller
crunchy qui sont les membres de vos
équipes belle de votre équipe et de
l'exode le nom et une adresse derrière
la consoeur saint-nicolas sac là on
vient de brûler le punch control tune
avec ma pensée amicale pour la licorne
tous nos derrières aujourd'hui que ce
que dit cameron tout nu qui notre
stagiaire pour cet été qui
c'était aujourd'hui il remplace nicole
parce que nicole y avait d'autres choses
à faire
exact lamy a déménagé conversations les
plus difficiles qu'ont eus je pense que
c'est facile à répondre on vient d'avoir
récemment ben ouais moi c'est sûr que la
conversation un calice c'était top
mais ça a été vraiment super en fait les
dernières semaines juste les dernières
c'est vraiment général ça a été tu
offres pour pour gasquet pour pour des
gobelins privilégier le ctd semaine
vraiment de remise en question de deux
conversations difficiles à vendre de
d'amis qui que tu te rends compte que
d'amis ou de connaissances qui se rend
compte que finalement était pas qui tu
pensé que tu es saha et ehrhoff pis puis
moi je me rappelle qu'en 15 ans qu'on a
parce que c'est à l'isq écrit à deux sur
ton instagram pour diriger une fin de
votre cas je me sauve n'ont rien appris
que demain médian est attendue je me
rappelle m'être avoir réfléchi il m'a
dit à stx est un sujet avec lequel je
sais pas si ça en même temps de
l'essayer parler de ça en ce moment que
ma pensée est loin d'être abouti sur
tout ce c'est nouveau c'est frêche c'est
extrêmement sensible mais on le fait
quand même
puis en sortant mais j'étais vidé mais
détruit mais j'ai attaqué ce qui venait
de se passer et chuté c'était une super
conversations mettent amèrement que j'ai
trouvé ça tough avoir entendu ces
affaires le terran tente son histoire
entendre entendent ces deux semaines de
calvaire complet pitt et qui confine à
la dénonciation était pire que
l'agression était de mise en moule
c'est une scène ont été
était forte un jeu 6/4 en peignoir le
tellement ben oui c'est ça pas souvent
mais alors parle tellement rien pis moi
je l'écouté je faisais les extraits puis
j'ai regardé les extraits puis je m'en
vais je m'en vais outils juju qui
pourront choisir se voulait aller jouer
au tennis après je fais de 15 je pensais
que j'allais pêcher sur moi c'est ça
aussi pied puisque cela a mené aussi
c'étaient des conversations entre amis y
mettons ouais c'est ça qui était si je
pense que c'est sûr de toutes les deux
les derniers mouvements ya eu des pics
et encore après l'autre ce qui est non
seulement c'est dans cette compétition
on a dans le public ici mais on compte
tous dans le privé avec et nos amis les
membres de notre famille tipi je dire on
a tout piqué notre famille qui tienne il
faut des livres pour rester sous tissu
s'était classé comme qui est commun
qu'on gère ce sont les dénonciations le
tipi ou non pas pendant une heure le
team et comment comment conjuguer études
du monde que le fait que le a préféré
question c'est qu'est ses confections
parce que le il y en a un qui risque
d'ingestion cancel tout le monde comme
ça est ce qu'on essaie de parler aux
gens qu'on connaît qui ont eu des
couples des comportements problématiques
et puis je pense qu'à aller salle amené
là la justice réparatrice qu'à l'appeler
de camions on va on fait pas juste quand
c'est lui tout le monde
on a essayé de régler le procureur
cherchait de leur ai dit ce type i lya
je parle à quelqu'un pitt y est maudit
on a juste a dit oui je sais pour un
fait indigo connu c'est fait car là où
tu m'étonnes en fait une tentative de
suicide depuis le train puis genre se
tient jeudi aussi grave les crimes que
tu commets je souhaite pas sa personne
je sois pas sa personne de s'enlever la
vie c'est les personnes qui qui qui qui
mairie 10e et personnes qui quittent le
choix de société
faites le
le bus pas de pousser les gens à vars
soul ses débuts c'est justement de dd
d'essayer que ce qu'ils ont fait des
progrès qu'il la fasse plus qui
guérissent qui a réglé dans enfants mais
s'ils sont complètement isolés josé une
personne complètement isolé cci rien de
bon pour la santé mentale qu'elle quitte
complètement exane en sait enfin que
parce que c'était la convention de loin
mais c'est là qu'on réalise the city
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un gros
gros problème d'éducation le terrain
qu'on a parce que tu quand ça sort
mathon qu'un groupe de nom qui sort je
peux je peux comprendre la maman tic
c'est sûr qu'il ya du monde mais côté le
pays en un peu partout mais quand ces
mêmes ensicaen s'est cassé à ce point le
cas il y en a autant gens qui sortent en
même temps c'est le c'est là que je
trouve un moment donné ça vient ça
devient un problème de société full sip
à toutes les femmes qui ont été victimes
de viols c'est toutes les femmes qui
sont victimes un certain degré de la
culture du viol pi2 deux-tiers des
propos misogynes de des remarques et des
attouchements non c'est moins violent de
dellys cefac si tout le monde sic c'est
l'autre j'étais jean vilar savoir n'ont
pas de carte rose aimée ou tantes et
morel
j'ai juste regardé l'extrême et je
trouve certains avancent qu'elles
devaient a dit qu'il ya plein de femmes
qui parlent qu'ils disent
amo chiche en sus jamais vécu ce home et
dans le fond j'ai des jeux véhicule
mon grand pas qui m'a pogné les q400 qui
s'occupe notamment la liste il a
effectué jeudi crise c'est même ce qui
ont prouvé qu'ils ont vécues par les
manuscrits qui est fait
chen story ce qu'était la démo j'étais
chanceuse jamais vu l'agression
pl dix ans mais peut-être cette fois
peut-être cette fois le boîtier
peut-être plus les ramasseurs une estive
lice mais à dix puis mais moi je me
compte chanceuse de porc avec
l'agression parce que rosa mais a dit un
extrait a dit la société est malade
sexuellement puis c'est vrai ouais c'est
vraiment vrai
puis justin tôt et je lisais un statut
de catane d'orienter puis à 10 le corps
des recherches sur internet dans un
google
ceci pour la pornographie le cas des
recherches qui a dit 80% des la
pornographique tu regardes ses désigns
oui un agression c'est pitié on en
regarde tout le temps puis on s'en rend
plus compte que ces sommes mais c'est
pareil je dois la fille adore le public
de l'arena nana une agression ce tir
outillés ou comment d'un emploi qui
s'engraisse y ont aussi fait qu on a on
en voit tout le temps de répéter c'est
oui
whittier on est capable un certain degré
de faire la différence entre l'art et la
hongrie fait la réalité
puis oui des fois mettons récré des
signes de même dans l'intimité avec un
partenaire consentants dans le jeu c'est
bien correct mais c'est impossible que
la quantité pour la griffe y consommer à
est pas un effet sur la psychologie du
monde
sur la question plus légèrement quel est
votre signe astrologique micro y va
c'est
dylan n'est pas même pas posé de
question j'ai je ne crois aucunement
n'ont plus aucune comme ça ça lors aucun
impact pour moi c'est non pas par moi
aussi j'y crois 0.2 bord mais je viens
chaque round & rice ça fait pas sens je
n'y crois pas je crois pas folle aux
signes astrologiques je suis acheteur
peut en effet sceptiques philosophe
américain je pense aussi que c'est bon
mangez cancer apprécié je suppose que ça
implique ou est bon alors c'est ça non
plus je peux pas te deum et on laisse y
voit le signe astrologique d'un bios le
jeune à vis avec ça dit il s'est fait
juger le pai rencontre une fille depuis
la veille a demandé c'est quoi son c'est
au nom sylvain ya dix ans et qui avait
fait ça marche
non mais c'est m quelqu'un qui se
délestent s'intéresse assume et on l'a
juste pour le fun c'est comme quelqu'un
trip se serrent les anneaux d'autres
crips l'astrologie le team et on oui à
une certaine depuis que touche expo vrai
métier que bon ça te fait réfléchir sur
rue lors les traits parenté du monde et
sans le savoir parce que c'est trop
important mais mendy que ça d impact sur
les décisions de prendre ta vie mais
pour moi il est probablement effective
avez vous déjà eu envie de taille elle a
dit non loin des questions culturelles
qui sont venus beaucoup sur nos livre
une musique préférée de les ramasser
tabarnak sommes un livre et un band qui
t'a marqué qui et n'importe quel livre
c'est andrew baricco c'est sûr certains
n'importe quel tellement plus j'ai
étudié la danse mais quand alessandro
baricco n'importe quel auteur de si
génial n'importe quel vous allez taper
pis musicalement je peux écouter mais
donne par ces faux culs qui arrêtait or
ce qui arrive aux jo piels kazakhstan
j'ai déjà l'on pose des mercis les
gueules noires et leurs savoirs ps je
connais aucune kirby discrédite
d'alameda premièrement on n'appelle pas
ça un pic puis deuxièmement connais au
moins trois tonnes
une loi ne les comptait adams tour là
mais moi j'ai dit je lai d'ébène que gmt
puis j'avais mon jeu l'aide arrivée dans
le camp sur tech gestion en est à 10 ans
je peux te le mettre pour sortir à sion
je le regardais j'ai dit j'ai dit non tu
peux pas mettre mon je l'admets deux
poteaux qui était déjà entendue détourné
mais donne ne peut pas non non tu peux
pas me mettre mon je l'admets donne pour
se désoler mais à un autre de moi mais
bon mais c'est la grosse mode même façon
ouais mais ça même samantha barnak mois
mais la farce et puis on en parlait
encore chez nous ouais ouais c'est le
monde et styrienne - au secondaire métal
parce que mon trip est sûre c'est ben là
parce que moi j'écoutais meeddm
métallique injecter deux jours de ce
prix j'écoutais morehead j'écoutais
megadeth le monde ryad - au secondaire
le l'état barmaki maîtrise l'aide et
berne
le même monde qui intimident les
métalleux dalta apporte aujourd'hui 59
tonnes de samatha barmax backelite de
lightning c'est mon album préféré
métalliques
c'est débile cet album là sauf que c'est
le jeu l'est du voile plus dans rue
l'album ride the lightning c'est lui qui
voit le plus
puis c'est la musique la moins
accessible de métal qu'ils rangent pas
d'accord et se barre qu'on ne le pensait
en justice for all bat méthodes ans et
ça c'est de la sémantique en dieu le
team et les fautes et riad le jeudi 1
mettons tout est que la personne de jean
tendues entre ses mains mais un
enchaînement n'a rien à voir avec ride
the lightning c'est même plus le même
thème de rendu l'alerté fejja quand je
vous dis mon avec les jeux les raids de
lightning je me dis tabarnak que steam
il est capable de dire c'est quoi de
colle à toulouse même dit qu'il aime
chanter style d'homme chanter la toundra
de lightning j'étais capable de me
chanter les rives de saône le vas-y
oui c'est parfait
mais même si c'est pour dire que la
musique et on lui préférait peut-être
mal donc mais moi mon band préféré ovale
times
c'est rideau et puis je reviens tout le
temps tu aimé tomber si j'écoute
vraiment beaucoup de musique puis je
sais que le temps des affaires mais
mettons s'ils ont des bonnes que met-on
je te quitte à retourner
je voudrais écouter ok computer vouloir
écouter énorme buzz l'album puis puis je
vois les re découvrir à chaque fois je
vais attendre des nouvelles affaires je
l'apprécié encore place à chaque fois
c'est comme je trouve que tellement de
profondeur des niveaux à cette musique
là que je peux l'écouter en est fini
s'il est vraiment une richesse à tous
les niveaux autant au niveau des des
accords d'aidé sont des paroles de tout
c'est vraiment moi je pense que c'est le
rire des groupes aussi vrai duel je
trouve qu'ils ceux qui travaillent aussi
le le times qui on est on est habitué
d'entendre beaucoup les mêmes
progressions d'accords les mêmes
mélodies ben pas les mêmes mais l'a dit
mais je faisais le des mélodies maton et
communautés sont des progressions
d'accords qui sont semblables mais on
n'est pas habitué maintenant d'avoir un
banc qui travaillent latin bruce hills
et puis moi je trouve qu'ils aiment
mettons dans d'enquêté par exemple il ya
vraiment des saules vraiment original
qu'il laissera dans cet album là je
trouve qu'ils cessent comme un c'est un
groupe indie mec qui a une vague électro
aussi gens qui manquent dans leur album
pop électro parce que je trouve qu'ils
travaillent mais tu vois c'est ça c'est
moi je trouve que je suis vraiment
d'accord avec toi qui vont pousser la
recherche sonore vraiment tentant des
nouveaux sont entendre la guitare 6,2
des ducs tourist johnny greenwood puits
d'eau bouillante et attend des sonorités
utilisation des pédales très attendu
avant puis dans les i dans les cinq ou
six et mot pour moi c'est juste un des
éléments qui est quitte génie parce que
tu mets ton il ya pas une toune non plus
plus je vois guy qui influent sur la
musique la pression familiale moi je
peux pas rien c'est maintenant il n'y a
pas eu le temps de crise où elles n'ont
plus qu'une progression d'accords
classique d'une tonne peuple ne pas
regarder lille comme anthony construite
au niveau de la forme nouveaux
désaccords ces petits lieux foule des
bétons de d'artistes jazz qui reprennent
la nouvelle z parce que c'est vraiment
riche niveau justement mélodique et
harmonique maintenant ok pour qu'ils
délivrent
je ne vois pas le dire mon livre préféré
mai dernier livre que j'ai lu je ne sais
pas de casser la femme qui fuit de à
l'esma où la valette qui sera bon puis
oui mais le savent quand ce faire un
petit bout tenu du potentiel ce temps-ci
de plongeurs stéphane larue on a parlé
beaucoup c'est normal et logique demandé
dès ma mère sara lee vraiment énormément
j'ai demandé des suggestions puis fait
le elle à lire des livres québécois de
100 livres par semaine fait que à ma
voix si c'est ce que gestion a mené sa
fin enfin petit club pour les autres à
quoi des québécois même temps le jeu de
la musique de stephenie clairement tout
c'est d'arrêter les trajectoires des
confettis de marie-ève chioukhs et non
la battre david goudreault ouais
apparemment c'est trash entre maxime et
puis en fait le lion il viendrait y
viennent de sortir dans une version
rester enfoncées 3 c3 livre bien écrit
une version réaliste et qui éléctro
livre the girls band mode à ton lit je
dirais vegan mais pas plate une ex
mégane les vapes la tombe de as connu un
tout les extraits de chez vous happe
tout cette enquête a préféré mais ça
vous donne une idée à quel point j libre
[Rires]
non mais non pauvres et kaka je lis
c'est vraiment des trucs hyper
spécifique l'enregistrement me trompe la
musique latine j'ai vraiment des plus
des trucs plus pour métier que juste
l'internaute mais sinon album assez
clame à l'hectare
je pense que ces gens parler j'en
parlais l'autre fois ce thème est tombé
mais mes goûts musicaux on changeait
tout le temps à travers ma vie mais les
stades c'est le seul album qui s'est
toujours resté dans mon top 3 mais ça je
pense que c'est la preuve
de ton album préfère était au côté
albums préférés c'est quand tu continues
à ti comme dom ce 10e titre je t'écoute
de nouvelles affaires de change de goût
mais il ya fort que tu reviens tout le
temps puis quand survient tout le temps
quelque chose parce que ça doit marquer
ça une place pour toi
elle est peut-être d'harmonium c'est
vraiment un grand mental bord souci de
compter dans le paquet avec ce matin à
100 comme la première fois que je les
écoutais pyjama vraiment marqué
j'élimine ans et d'un cd player que j'ai
fait ou chez quelque chose qui se passe
le sorcier c'est ici un haut niveau ses
droits
puis il ya une question qui revient
souvent qu'ils quittaient dans les
questions les plus populaires l'invité
rêver puis justement je pense que serge
fiori on a parlé l'autre jour ensemble
ça sert chérie ça serait un livre ticket
jeu très pressante jal est à côté du
chalet familial ou est ce que c'est et
par m village
toi moi les gars je vais changer
complètement témoin j'écoute du beaucoup
beaucoup de rappeler beaucoup beaucoup
soin des yeux les pythies tout est
aléatoire de son mensuel facteurs les
albums les noms des fois j'ai juste 1000
tonnes de la plus importe quoi je vais
avec du eminem sinon de 1 200 ha ben
classiques wi-fi majeur tournage en
retournant mnm chemin s'il ya un dégoût
et s envole times ouais mais en fait je
retourne plus souvent à ma bio de faux
twisted fantasy de cagnes et quand j'y
retourne ici toujours quand je retourne
toujours aucune tonnes qui m'aura cet
album là est bon de la première note à
la dernière c'est vrai c'est débile
c'est un génie de la musique mais c'est
vrai qu'il dit l'oeil a raison c'est un
génie de la musique faudrait que ça
arrête là sa première référence oms
c'est un gars qui débrayent santé
mentale qui est non non traitée qui je
pense même qu'il le dit dans son speech
qui prenait plus ses médicaments avec 20
kg et amène ses fournisseurs et surtout
et où l'autre jours en disant m 2,9 au
cochon de musicman mais qu'est ce que
tous annoncent un album bientôt je pense
comme ça ça me mine à mal mais on est
qu'ils aient ce qui fait ça aussi pour
moi je pense pas qu'ils mettaient à ce
point je pense qu'il ya vraiment moi je
pense qu'il est vraiment déboussolé
complètement c'est celui d'écrire écrit
à la hausse et à moins que ça tout ça
soit mascarade
depuis le début pour chamand jusqu'à
parler mais ça me semble tirée par les
cheveux - n'diaye 25 % de la population
qui croît des choses encore plus de 6
les parlers les tweets écailles listings
ce petit fils faire face au problème
j'ai pas pu pleinement partagé ça j'ai
pas vu c'est quand même une question
une question qui venait beaucoup c'est
comme en savoie la colocation puis est
ce que vous tapez sur les nerfs
j'avais dit qu'il boit il commande qui
siégea vous travaillez ensemble et en
son genre web des phoques
comment quelqu'un qui vous fait pourquoi
comment ça c'est que métier mettons le
travail ensemble dont on ne voit pas
très souvent pour le travail
puis je pense que je pense que si on
avec des ménages est ensemble plutôt
dans nos vies ont arrêté plus tôt sur
moi mais là je pense qu'on les deux on
se connaît assez on se connaît assez
individuel bt moi je me connais assez
cadenassé mais je connais aussi assez
les deux pour savoir qu'est ce qui
ferait chier l'eau puis faisons pas ce
exact quand je finis de manger chamade
et celle du sud - laisse pas traîner
janvier jour exact
et c'est comme ça que ça veut là que
lorsqu'il faut faire la mettrais ma
naissance à 4,24 le cpo le cresson de 28
ans fait avc non ce n'était pas la seule
à faire
peut-être que si je t'ai 100% tout le
temps le cam en il y aurait des petits
enfants mais le à date
brillante des calendriers respectifs
vous allez tout le temps tu y vas l'on
se voit comme je pense côté n'ont eu
aucun problème de ce nouveau le hockey
en qui en sortent un pass à notre niveau
parce que leur niveau il est au-de 2 bis
qui demandent comment ça vous
honnêtement dans toute l'histoire des
influences qui m'attend je pense aux
débits témoin gênant que je pensais sans
vie mais ne répond pas qui ni quand tu
commences comment ça va honnêtement non
mais ça va bien je pense que cette
question n'était pas me place dans ta
vie l'a dit qu'on y est le genre avec
l'art m'acheter une bonne place dans ma
vie tout comme je disais tantôt moche
moi quelque chose qui me rend heureux je
pense c'est ben si m ma job mais rares
utile mais plus que ce cd c'est
travailler pour vous faire faire
développer un
un art qui en fait d'avoir l'impression
de participer à un mouvement - tautil
vie ou un peu avec le véganisme ou
ci-dessus part parce que tu fais tu
contribue-t-il à faire à faire évoluer
ses mouvements le puits moi mettons ce
bain dans l'univers faut s'en rappeler
parce que c'est facile à oublier mais
depuis quand ils oublient des fois dans
la tête dans mardi
je trouve ça plate en crise mais il faut
que tu te rappelles le seul à faire mais
oui oui c'est bon toi lexsi commence à
votre honnêtement moi honnêtement ça va
moyen ça va bien ça c'est sûr je pense
que j'ai une personne positive dans dans
ma vie en général
l'oeil plusieurs choses pendant le creux
vide qui a fait tous mes projets se sont
soit arrêtés soit reporté comme comme
pleinement mais dans ma situation c'est
que ce soit je sais pas financièrement
ou pas ça va très vite je sais qui il
l'espère dans l'aria qui est tout le
temps des gens pire que toi si tu dis
dans la finalité que ça ça va à lille
était même et c'est ce factice jusque le
coc vide le que ce soit les
manifestations la danse à fait juste
tout le temps pensé en background des
pensées qui au lieu de dire cool j'ai
fini ma journée tout va bien arrêté le
hamas qu télé tu penses à un sujet ou
peut-être que je pense que dans le fond
ce combat mais je pense que c'est ça je
filtre je fais ce que tu dis même parce
que les derniers
kottmann des derniers mois le complet
depuis depuis le début du confinement
les méthodes mais moi je revenais je
revenais de californie où est-ce qu'ils
venaient de finir mon mémoire ou est-ce
que l'on chantait nat livre de recettes
ce qui était sans club salle est belle
anguille mais bien
pas à décoller ça les a réunis mais puis
après sus de convoquer le fait que leur
le coc vite frappe pour vrai isolement
on ferme tout l'été qui s'en venait
maugis j'aurai moi je te regarde et et
je déteste l'hiver j'ai toujours détesté
livres à ma famille le sais j'ai fait
des dépressions saisonnières
cleese vent puis le l'été s'en venait
mais là non ça ce repos était comme
comme tu aurais pris l'été depuis le
après solide
le mouvement black largement dû à la
presse les dénonciations fit et jamais
je me rappelle je te le dis en effet
j'aimerais juste ce que s'arrête pendant
une semaine comme que tout art est le
genre on arrête c'est tous des
mouvements qui sont ils trop positifs
de justice sociale je suis d'accord mais
là en ce moment pour moi en ce moment
faut que ça arrête qu'en plus c'est que
j'ai pas le oui il parle de juste shot
down tout mais shit de juste fermer mon
cell juste laisser cela parce que je me
dis faut quand même que je reste l'autre
il faut quand même que je sois impliqué
pour quand même que je le sache qu est
ce qui se passe ici puis puis je soldes
comme tarifs chez vous plus supporter on
fait 10 puis le tu veux juste passer le
temps christophe même piscine non
seulement tu vois ça passait mais
s'arrête pas quand tu le vois ce ton si
sa récente atteint que ça reste le
pilote dire avec ce qui m'est je
comprends ce que tu veux dire mon pays
je pense que la dernière dernières
semaines le savoir mieux que ça et que
ça l'a été pendant pour moi
personnellement ça vaut mieux que ça a
été depuis depuis le début du conflit
oui mais qu'est ce que tu me déprimer le
style avec la vague de dénonciations en
arrivant avec la vague de l'irena a tout
le temps les témoignages sordides les
enfermer
mesure du monde que c'est maintenant sûr
du monde qu'on connaît ainsi sur des
jeux des moyens de mes bons amis qui est
qu'il ya eu des témoignages dessus
puisque m
tabarnak même genre mais vraiment il y a
vraiment fallu qu'à un moment la neige
j'aime moins pas complètement arrêté
mais il ya vraiment fallu man et que je
me dise qu'elle juge plus j'arrête d'y
aller parce que ses matons témoin mois
en plus en travaillant ici comme tel et
en étant d'ailleurs la console derrière
les podcasts et puis je me plut tôt le
chiot le pot mais sur celui des podcasts
pas de sens a vu le début blackliner
tout tout est lui-même qu'il peut
s'informer sur le mouvement des oem
pauvre il y en a eu vraiment vraiment
beaucoup tu puisses torpeur
c'est qu'à un moment donné tu y tiens
quand et que des podcasts du monde toute
la journée tarifs chez vous du temps
c'est un style facebook le c soit
d'autre la grande marche ce soit des
dénonciations du truc comme ça c'est que
man et j'ai réalisé que ça a commencé
vraiment affecté mon moral en place et
loctudy faites comme moi le chic option
maginez si on n'est ni victime de
racisme ni qui ça nous affecte t la
vague des négociations ça m'affecter
lire ce qui jetait le hamman et michel
jeffrey un break qui sait mener ma santé
mentale ça marche put imagine les
victimes tic
oui en plus les témoignages sa retenue
et que leur propre trop mais c'est fou
c'est moi je vous le dis le départ
rapport m blacklight malheureuse
absolument il ya eu beaucoup tout il ya
eu beaucoup des podcasts par rapport à
cela dans les derniers temps puis
absolument toutes les gueules noires qui
sont passés au studio ils ont peut-être
raconté la même affaire c'est qu'ils
seront toutes mettons arrêté par la
police aucune raison
fact et à un moment donné c'est pas
juste quelque chose que quelques
personnes vers le cic tout le monde
petit fils
ces facs et là tu vois c'est vraiment
vraiment problème de société et il faut
vraiment changer sur piste et donne même
une autre là on se l'est dit cette
semaine on a fait long on vient de faire
beaucoup de podcasts engagé beaucoup de
cash lorsqu'on sait on ne réfléchit
beaucoup sur ce sujet le plomb s'est dit
là on va peut-être en faire des plus
louches dans les prochaines semaines
parce qu'on n'avait pas été reconstruit
d'en faire parce que je pense que c'est
important pitié quand il à faire
l'arrivée
je sais pour moi pour nous c'était une
responsabilité amener ses propos comme
tellement gros qu'ils étaient des
pourparlers grâce à farina pas de
cassure pic avant de commencer sa chaîne
youtube ont annoncé ceci se fera par les
pistes importantes mais mais c'est ce
système que ce semaine après semaine
ça serait trop lourd trop lourd bilan
bien simplement même pour le monde qui
écoutent amman et commentaires dans le
juste avant à double comme quoi les tic
ont ri le oui il ya eu foule
commentaires aussi de gens à lille à
votre timing ans maman pige à oreille
vos podcasts depuis depuis une coupe
d'épisodes et pink ou deux semaines
genre si c'est vraiment au top on
apprend foule puis suivront des sujets
importants puis partiront le faux l'upi
trilogie si la journée qu'on a sorti
webster puis tout le monde a partagé que
c'est elle est l'espèce des d'apogée de
tout le monde parlait du mouvement black
rider c'est exact et jetés comme pitié
tout le crédit revient aux invités dans
six d'entre eux à webster mais j'avais
quand même un choeur et sentiment
d'avoir fait la bonne chose d'avoir
comme parler de se donner la parole et
qui compte vraiment pertinent qu'il ya
vraiment beaucoup de monde qu'à l'écouté
ça l'est vraiment tu rentres dans tête
du monde c'est son message avait rejeté
comme fiat va envoyer pensée était quand
on arrivait pour poster c'était le
black-out yvan muller née juste non mais
si la sécurité est ce qu'on le fait pipi
belge mais je vous ai parlé c'était
juste pourquoi le ferai pas parce que le
sujet c'est celui ci contre et passion
par l'édition recevait
quelqu'un qui justement c'est commentée
par la chine pense pas qu'on l'aurait
promote que non c'est un excellent ami
ouais vraiment hockey le trust a volé
glace à bienne vous bougez pas de
problème ça va bien ça va bien non mais
pauvre est petit ça je me suis levé le
pas si longtemps le ju jitsu podcast
barge tard dépression baladera fois
qu'on s'est vus là des réunions le
huawei m'avait dit qu'il ne viendrait
pas de gens qui donnent l'impression pas
les travaux pour les prochains mois
casse la gueule on dirait que quand j
lui la question tantôt commence à vous
honnêtement ça faisait longtemps que je
m'étais arrêté pour votre question plus
je me suis créé c'est vrai comment ça
vous dit et qui savent pas
j'ai vu c'est vraiment moi ça va bien en
ce moment je suis sur le j'ai eu
d'ailleurs plus rough pitié des ide des
relations qui ont chié type ce temps un
peu de l'âme a pu aussi un espèce
d'absence j'avais une absence de
direction
j'essaie de pau où je m'en allais
exactement
j'avais des questions que tu es pas
capable de répondre puis j'ai un peu
répondu à ces questions le prendre et
que ça surtout pour toi avant le
confinement tu commençais à avoir du
vent dans les voiles
ouais niveau créatif professionnels
c'est sûr que ça a produit le
confinement ça cette époque j'ai perdu
pas la faire partir en début
contrepartie d'aidés vraiment justement
un jour de taille mais le fond mais ça
m'a aussi permis de jeu thomas
développer d'autres choses réfléchir et
et puis je suis pas que du négatif
le team honda dans le fond ce métier-là
mettons je te mentir les bonnes
questions de genre ou où je me vois dans
le futur habitent et maintenant
m'installer vraiment et puis comment ça
va ressembler à quoi tout ce pilot j'ai
quand même répondu à ces questions le
jeu pas encore fait mais juste le fait
de bain je peux le dire mais je suis pas
mal je vois certains qui étaient moi je
suis tout le temps été moitié québec
moitié montréal drogue
non mais en fait je pense que je vois
installé à québec puis je monte à
montréal fallait pas de gasoil du monde
régulièrement mais que je vois me baser
le puis je veux concentrer mes affaires
le pied c'est ce plus jeune je le vois
je l'imaginé c'est clair si c'est
possible dit qu'ils rendraient que le
juste d'avoir ce jeu moins inquiets pour
l'avenir je - comme et père d'une fille
comme je m'en veux qu'ils pensent qu'ils
sont avant tout les sens mais ça vous
sait si c'est rassurant je pense puis
justement le sentiment ktk mais qu'il
faut faire dans ma vie et nana na na na
na tous ces questionnements l'eau le ccc
of band boulanger demande mais ils n'ont
que je vois que kim 10 toxiques et syd
matters les critiques il est des
commentaires qui laisse des likes les
affaires qui ont les voit pas assez
souvent fac et on vous reconnaît on vous
aime bien mou largement le truc le plus
facteurs qui est arrivé au studio sfr de
pâques à sedan c'est pas tant celui ci
de ce qui s'est passé ici en 6 4 c'est
la chose la plus grosse foxy
probablement de loin les pas de gaz
en attendant le jeu cast adamo qui reçut
des anticipateur c'était juste si je me
souviens c'était moi qui était acquis la
technique sous le nom de la console qui
j'étais même jeté comme base et puis
j'avais rien primerica est-ce que
j'hallucine ce qui se passe à l'abri de
regarder souvent alors ouais alors
qu'est-ce que je serai 6,7 sur gestion
maintenant les conditions gagnantes pour
un podcast automaticien conditions
perdant réunit les autres arrivent là en
état on lit le plus vite possible espada
vous parlez on me dit ça mais ça c'est
elle expliqué les plus fugaces les plus
vues pillet
le témoin est vraiment dès que je parle
t'il de châtillon le studio parfait des
podcasts ont fait le pégase adam oates
ah oui j'ai vu et les anticipateur c'est
sa force et de loin
c'est de loin la voix la plus grosse
brosse après un podcast ci même pas
proche même si les deux podcasts
accusant le premier pas tiens c'est
qu'ils ont tout et on est allé au lave
après les deux fous moi à manu jbeli way
tête et aller juste fromage aller
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout de la nuit
et deux fois la première fois on est
allé au love avec toi python ex web et
relax mais apprécions notre virée ce
home is ville et puis même chez défense
de l'école s'est même puis l'autre fois
après c'est commencer par beach dvd le
podcast on avait de la bise hdz apparaît
la fin premier podium 2e biche des
moniteurs d'école c'est aussi même pis
les deux sessions de vrai cette folle et
sa fille ni moins le fun mais
mettons-les la semaine après pour moi le
mais qu'est-ce qui est toujours pas
entrer dans plus de détails mais qu'ils
risquaient j'étais chaud un certain dead
sur mon coeur et qu'on a fini nicole
linda est venue une zone mais non tu
allais dans un parc
ma soeur était le rire j'ai failli
oublier mon portefeuille mais n'apparaît
il y avait 1-1 à diesse un sans abri qui
l'avait genre on est revenu on est
revenue au parc on a fait j'ai fait
clairement comprendre le ferions nerveux
n'ont pas je peux te rappelles de ce jeu
me rappelle même posé on est revenue au
pas je pars à courre semaine j'en arrive
parce qu'on était assis mon portefeuille
histoire d'achever genre tabarnak le il
ya un monsieur qui arrive il fait ce que
c à vous sur mon portefeuille concierge
la plage pense non c'était 500 abris qui
remonte et les canettes ou j'avoue le
chevet genre ouais là je prends mon
portefeuille je la regarde
j'avais comme 120 pièces de d'un cache
cache
je regarde le 120 pièces est encore le
jeu tabarnak shore 40 pillage dit merci
monsieur sur 48h dit merci monsieur
mathias c'est pas nécessaire je croyais
au tpo nécessaire comme arme à qui rien
non rien pris dans mon portefeuille de
leur ramener way a été apprécié ontario
miss villeray moi je me rappelle avoir
marché longtemps aussi apprennent déjà
reparti de miss villeray pourquoi
retourner chez vous il aa tête à londieu
aussi débile il a amélioré il ya quinze
ans par chimène de ce marché sur le pont
non je me suis rendue jusqu'aux pompes
apprécié j'ai pris un taxi moi je
voulais sur cet axe est blessé au visage
retrouvé des traces de villeray jusqu'au
pont jacques-cartier de malades
coli partie et fait beaucoup de mal à
prendre un taxi
ces genres
du marché ni l'autre ouais mais pour ma
part c'est la plus grosse brosse liés ou
pas de casque
ok les parties noël avec nous quatre
puits avaient l'embarras dans le temps
et qu'on s'est torché
non mais non mais j cc s'est moqué de
moi mais maintenant c'est moi qui
ramasse et belmont lendemain la même je
me serais parti ne me rappelle pas
d'avoir quitté le banc c'est moi plus je
me réveille chez nous j'ai fait à
marmagne même temps j'ai beau pays je
vous écris je fais les guesh patti pas
payer le jeu passionnantes occupait
belge des vues payer en fait tu nous
avais dit tout est beau tout est bon le
lan meddtl fch part j'ai pas payer tout
cela va finalement devoir élever les
relevés du studio et ça c'est le studio
mais le relevé du studio même on a bu un
tas barnes est la plus élevée les
éleveurs de l'homme c'est palma les deux
belles les plus élevés que j'ai payé ma
vie telle attaque bien rester on a pris
1,20 et blanc
[Musique]
demandée pour un goût minérale
il faut apprendre quelque chose déjà
quand je suis arrivé là vous avez déjà
commencé c'était ça va commencer
on a craint pas de casse pipe mykeul
mais bon moi il m'a envoyé une vidéo de
moi d'en chasser ces gens là sont lisais
déjà chanté je te défoncer des jeux
qu'on était dans le champ en direction
je pense non chanteix bob je connaissais
les paroles au complet puisque rien
d'ailleurs je te défonce m animaux boom
desjardins ça a été mon premier gros
toutes les caches tu es vraiment jeune
je suis pas un peu tard mais ce soir la
radio baron et tout ben trop chaude puis
je t'embrasse et nicole parce que je
veux dire qui étaient ces sages murray
dit tantôt c'est la seule fois de ma vie
que j'ai été malade au bord puis
amnistie qui était juste à atteindre
même tu étais petit est absent n'était
plus le même tu te le disent que leur
rebond mais la clé je te paye je suis
bien à nicolas ce balai à toilettes des
clôtures à nantes où elle est plutôt
comment ça vous remet que moi je me
souviens des terrains de la toile est
sorti des toilettes retourner voir les
gauches que tony est un genre a attribué
leur éclat guerre je venais genre dix
minutes plus tard sort de la toilette tu
dis amen
mais si nous avons attendu
[Rires]
pratiquement rien fait en fait ça alors
où est ce qu'on se parle actuellement je
la regrette plus rien d hugo dirait des
classes qui demandent si on nous traite
un podcast type si fox était un peu dans
le même ordre d'idées la mêlée pas caché
qu'ils en utilisant dans le bus je sais
que c'est pas le truc de noël de l'année
avant le circuit avec avec nos deux ex
se je me souviens que j'étais pas pire
chaud il ya un pas de caste qui non
disponible maintenant qu'ils achetaient
chrouda question tantôt en nature mais
il ya des pas de caste qu'on a enlevé
des paquets ces dernières sont à suite
aux dénonciations il ya un dépôt
d'interrogations sur lesquels je t'ai
pas pire chaud pis y'a quelqu'un qui
demande cam trop neuf 9 mois puis à pour
moi people6 mettons après une soirée
arrosée ensemble on a déjà dormi ans en
bas on adore bien si ce que tu veux dire
c'est dormez sûrement d'avril à mai
j'avais dit je t'ai chez vous pilotes gt
par un puits par une blonde à l'époque
tu dormais avec puis je vous rappelle on
était le parti mais je peux en fait pas
tu dormais avec à ce moment là mais tu
aller dormir avec clairement dormait
dans son lit
je me rappelle d'avoir 10 mn je peux
prendre mon champ je peux tu à dormir
dans son lit plus médias et pas de
stress plus je me sens beaucoup mieux
que tu as pu tablons plus à ce moment là
qu'un camion disparaissait sans rien
dire
on disait
je me rappelle est ce qu'il fallait je
te dis c'était un battement je te dis un
batman ça veut dire que 1,4 au pot pour
moi je suis parti je ne suis pas rue
pleut je me suis réveillé avec la lueur
du jour dans ton lit avec tous à table
on pile je te regarder chez les ch'tis a
maintenant 13 ans on était pas mal
acquis qui étaient au milieu trois mois
bush comme la crème de l'arrêt ou la
grèce à chaque fois chaque rame pourquoi
à qui on est à 3 du crunch in me line 91
c'est ce qu'à une bonne question je
pense pas si grandes choses quand même
une très bonne question êtes-vous ouvert
aux relations de couple ouverte à
l'échangisme interrogations qui répond
tout va commencer
cool je n'ai pas besoin de pression ce
qu'a expliqué stress - non je le plâtre
le ballon frappé sur elle
je sais pas comment dire aussi c'est
souvent dans les podcasts souvent
d'entendre des opinions divergentes par
rapport à ce même mois
j'ai regardé par année ça tout va bien
un chien sont vieux lorsque tes parents
ils vont pas ne sont jamais les données
que je peux être sûr d'être seul nom
mais même moi pas programme woippy ma
relation j'espère pis j'aimerais ce que
ce soit avec elle toute ma vie ok mais
tu y mets ton mais ton couple ouvert de
genre chacun peut faire ce qu'il veut de
son bord je pense que c'est vraiment
difficilement possible
pourtant pour cent des patients ça
fonctionne mais mettons serait pas
ouvert à un truc qui inclut vous deux
mais d'autres personnes je pense pas
avoir la vision ou de quechua l'opa de
penser à elle
quelqu'un d'autre que pis même qu'il
soit un homme ou une femme je dise j'ai
de la misère avec ses raisons puis après
je suis pas mal sûr de ce qu'il est mais
je respecte ceux qui veulent faire des
coupes le voir papa tu voulais essayer
n'importe quoi même mois
moi je suis bien dedans puis j'aimerais
c'est que ce soit comme ça
walton bâti sur ce genre d'affaires
qu'il n'ya pas de bonne réponse mais
c'est vite le montant exact mais on
dirait que des foires 20% de pression
des denrées dedans mais des fautes qui
auraient coûté un podcast ou ici un
podcast est en tout cas peu importe mais
des fois tu pour la question quand tu
entends des affaires puisque je suis
rendu pas dormi
y'a pas de normalité mais est-ce que je
suis rendu je pense que la bonne façon
classique classé qui se remet en
question mais je pense que la majorité
des gens sont entre guillemets classique
je pense que les gens je pense aussi
mais mes yeux de plus en plus une
ouverture à des enfants de rennes puis à
se poser la question puis à être
vraiment à part les prix puis ce qui est
une bonne chose d après ce que chacun se
pose la question c'est qu'est-ce qui
qu'est ce qu'ils baissent effet tournoi
demain matin toi tu pressé avec keita
blanc nez avec table handball cool je
content pour toi ne se soit pas avec moi
mais je jouais à seulement faire avec
toi c'est toi qui vois des dames et ces
quatre semaines ce aussi une excellente
question puis je pense que je pense que
je pense que peu importe c'est quoi si
c'est fait avec le consentement des deux
le respect des deux à gaz que ces
quarante nuits épiques c'est moi je
réussis sauter au film semble matin
c'est moi personnellement ça m'est
jamais arrivé maintenant est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui est possible que
je vois mais tendue au chemin du roy
hill sa blonde qui ont l'air de vives
même parfait bonheur puis que je pense
que seppi puis je me dis que les sas
c'est possible c'est tout à fait puis
dakar n'est la situation va arriver que
je vous ça va ça va m'arriver à moi
parce que je vois est requinqué que je
suis juste pas je sais pas you know
symbian os et moi je pense que je
pourrais potentiellement être voir
l'intérêt sans moi je pense que non mais
je pense damas c'est qu'ici c'est une
affaire on sait pas c'est sophie
croissante
je pense que ça s'applique aux
fonctionnaires de 11 justement comme se
dit on se respecte on communique
il faut vraiment que ça soit ultra clair
ultra discuter ultra tout puis qui a
déjà pu tout art validés parce que je
paye des bâtiments est soigné mais katie
sa peur je sais et pirelli d'affaires
germaniques une relation de long terme
très man est juste un petit spécial
tendance a pu comme juste suspense il
faut faire du bien mais simplement je
pense que ça peut même rapprocher notre
d'un coup peut-être mais c'est sans
doute que ça peut sans doute
nicole est toujours qu elle s qui a
esquivé la question je sais qu'à lille a
tout le talent et pis c'est exact est-ce
que vous m'entendez bon ok voilà
mais non je pense qu'on en a parlé en
bonne place avec cassandra bouchard je
pensais le sera pas non si on n'y arrive
pas c'est que ce que contient ce concept
classique avait comme beaucoup beaucoup
d'infidélité ans les coupes c'est
énormément piste est un fléau pour les
couples atypiques et possiblement qu'il
y avait un problème fondamental avec la
façon avec laquelle on voyait un copieux
a claqué la la société la construction
sociale congé des fêtes données d'un
couple était peut-être fondamentalement
fausse considérant que l'instinct humain
faisait qu'il y avait une énorme
majorité des coupes des ménages qui
commettait l'adultère si on avait fait
le vote dans l'intervalle 75% quelqu'un
qui avait été dans un couple qui avait
eu l'adultère qui se dépasser et
l'adulte en mai l'effectif compte c'est
avec castrés qui a peut-être qu'il y
avait une cave est un problème
fondamental avec la façon que laquelle
on se faisait montre et le couple
traditionnel peut-être le temps dans le
fond de réforme est un peu cette genre
des deux visions le de ces couacs au
moins monsieur j'imagine que le
mouvement social qui va venir
éventuellement vrai je pense qu'on ne va
pas m'associer aux
tk par les activistes pour la pour
déformer la vision traditionnelle et
rationnelle des coupes attendait un peu
avant de marcher dans vue mais mois
maintenant par rapport à sortie moi
maintenant je pourrais pas être dans un
couple ouvert mais quelque chose que je
pense que je pourrais être sans problème
par contre 6,1 un couple avec une genre
des bonnes dates limites mathilde genre
sexy mais tant que la fille au bout de
deux ans mettant à part en voyage pas un
fake ticket au bout de deux ans
maintenant cette histoire là ça va se
finir facteur important dans une
relation en sachant maintenant qui va
avoir une fin dans un an ou deux mais
ton moi je pense que je serai réalisé
avec ça serait le fun pendant ce temps
le moi j'ai déjà été dans une relation
comme ça je devrais quand une fille qui
était française qui s'en allait
travailler dessus cinq cents à l'est qui
est en échange d'étudiants qui
repartaient en france enfin la session
puis il y avait aucune chance que ça
aille plus loin que le moment qu'ils
repartent en france et puis ça a été ça
l'a été deux mois
vraiment de la bombe vraiment de la
bombe le genre très en avance dans les
gars c'est la bombe américaine
l'autre contrainte époque vraiment bon
et après ça après ça il ya eu une
journée où est ce qu'il y avait des
larmes puis c'est fini mais une journée
de larmes pour deux mois deux bombes
c'est correct avez vous vu le film
québécois les faux tatouages non ça
réalisateur bah oui ben c'est ton frère
inconnu qui s'appelle pascal réalisateur
québécois le qui commence à faire
vraiment beaucoup parlé de l'huile qui
commence à faire une grosse réputation
d'ailleurs il a été nommé en sélection
officielle au festival de cannes ce qui
est énorme pour son dernier film il
surfait mieux faites avant le faux
tatouages très peu sur la prémisse genre
de relation avec une date de péremption
qui sont excellents films directement
notamment
étant cassée m pourquoi pourquoi
embarquer là-dedans pis tu peux quand
même l'avoir parce que je sais pas le jt
est spacieux s'embarque dans une
relation en passant maintenant que ça va
pour la vie et ses hommes et non mais
bel exemple
j'essaie de penser quand que je sais pas
moi j'ai sparks pour la vie c'est chaud
c'est difficile car tu bois pour patty
silex à venir j'ai dit pourquoi tu
embarques et au delà 100% team étant que
c'est ce que tu voyais d'autres
personnes qu'un nom parlé d'excusés face
à bath et nice médecine
je compte apporter de la bave et vous y
eut les chimistes de paulo coelho le
livre que tout le monde a lu une fois en
voyage baisse et clis qui dit c'est que
peu importe si ou la destination
l'important c'est le voyage de m c'est
après la fois j'entends c'est cela
puisse paraître les autres stars qui
peut-être parce qu'il les connaît en
audio ou quiconque qui saisissent pas le
deuxième niveau de mon commentaire
mais l'alchimiste de paulo coelho si
vous voulez parler de dénaturer
quelqu'un dit pas parce que tout le
monde a déjà parlé de la chimie c'est
extrêmement clichés de parler de dieu
puis met le poing l'alchimie ces temps
de dire que la destination n'importe pas
autant que le voyage c'est comme à dix
elle aussi comme dans notre groupe de
six thèmes que tu trimes sous protection
si c'est exact c'est ça la littérature
torpeur est un peu un lag le monde qui
parle de la chimie ce n'est la
messagerie chimiste est quand même
pertinent par rapport à ce genre de
conversation qui est vraiment les gens
sont oubliées sli obsédé par le sexe
excusé j'ai eues on le dit tantôt on le
dit tantôt les titans tous ceux qui
verront beaucoup de cas des questions à
caractère sexuel mais le jeu voyait unaf
vraiment cheap vraiment à voir avec la
sexualité non mais j'essaie non mais
c'est ça
non mais c'est le monde va permettre aux
questions sexuelles
ce que je veux c'est que toutes les
autres questions qui rien c'est qu'elle
montre de caractère sexuel sur scène et
après si celle-là est vraiment iv
d'outré nicole toi comment ces six cas
la dernière fois que tu as pleuré et
j'ai pleuré qu'elle aurait sûrement sur
moi je dirais vite d'un manque de
caractère
quand je me suis séparé que mon cd sorti
du temps de ma mère j'ai pu connaître
les us navy à web et web mais humblement
mais après c'est moins peut-être que mai
prochain des firmes de fonds
non c'est vraiment vraiment or c'est
vraiment au pij pas pourquoi en plus mon
nom pareil il pleure souvent en pleurs
surgelés vu quelquefois ne tombe pleuré
en écoutant ça lui met mais non on
dirait je suis pas ça me touche pas
assez à ce niveau là mais je peux
maintenant un film triste mais non ce
n'est pas mon lecteur état de
l'existence même la tène l'exil 12
minutes et que sa chérie plaire en
chambre en faisant sa tête de bayal non
à toi lexsi ci dessus je pense que que
vient de là on était tous un peu moi
j'étais avec mes parents pendant que
vides et ma blonde floppy à fleur de
peau puis 10e on parlait de films et les
émissions dany d'animaux qui souffre et
des animaux oui mais oui vraiment étroit
les troupes ont pas été volé quand c'est
arrivé j'ai soudain classique le toit
juste le le chien il au point où je sais
pas trop le piler le saut final mais
grosse opération qui coûte et cheveux 2
le trophée qu à part les cinq garçons je
mets les deux fils etienne sait pas à
qui je peux pleurer lâche toi je pense à
l'arrivée la semaine d'après avec sur la
même émission un autre jour deux fois
par semaine on exclut les les vidéos de
quand je regardais dire sur youtube
genre et de sports de mains
vous savez c'est parce que juste pour le
sport ça me touche particulièrement fait
que je vois quand je vois des gens
réaliser leurs rêves
je me mets à pleurer mais donc exclus
sont évidemment après ma séparation je
peux pleurer beaucoup mieux comme il ya
des moments précis où est ce que je
pleure et le thé mettons là une soirée
aussi un souvenir vraiment ultra précis
qui paul dans la tête le genre même à
pleurer comme une fois qu'une fausse
hier d'après ce que mme chabot est-ce
que tu mets à sa place j'aurais fait
mentalement mais ton coeur on est des
souvenirs que moi j'affectionne
particulièrement mettons le logement
rappelle pleut ça m'est arrivé une
couple de fois peut-être deux ou trois
fois un confinement est comme une soirée
où est ce que j'écoutais la pop carré de
papel plein espèces sur pause même à
penser à quelque chose le même apport ce
[Musique]
mois j'ai pleuré veulent vraiment
récemment j'arrive des voyages de la
madeleine enfants et je compterai
pamiers aujourd'hui un petit accrochage
familiale mettons le cpie sap au
téléphone puis plus rien du tout
mais sans la fin de ma dernière relation
j'ai pleuré beaucoup grosses questions
posées et qui comme un quelqu'un non
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu une dette
avec un éviter de podcasts allez-y les
gars nicole non moi j'ai ma demande a
été canalisée connor se battre non plus
puisque 2 se veut aller en tête avec une
note
on ne supprime les filles incroyable
elle est intelligente intéressante donc
dans l'absolu probable
ben je dans l'absolu je ré endetter bras
mais aussi votre cas mais jamais dans
nos coeurs
[Rires]
non mais non moi en fait moi non plus en
fait puis moi je pense qu'ils étaient
juste incapable de faire un move avec
une fille direct latam apporte là cette
offre mais j'étais incapable de faire
cette offre ça prend c'est ça va arriver
non plus mais c'est sûr tu sais il y en
a eu les matons des faits qui sont
arrivés j'ai tout est vraiment belle
mais on a reçu plusieurs balles faciles
ah oui mais je suis pas pitié c'est
aussi que l'argent un contexte de
travail j'ai balancé ça mais tout aussi
la manne est le genre on évite positif
de demande pas ce qu'on veut à la tête
avec ça serait problème
[Rires]
on voit pas le on va pas le j'ai fait
qu'une question de temps en temps à m'y
opposer qui est vraiment encore un autre
niveau la réponse est non lp la croix
elle peut fournir à qui j'ai une
question qui pour à caractère sexuel
feriez-vous un podcast avec chomsky nous
dérider gauge nerveux podcast non pas
moi moi je dirais non mais je dirais pas
que c'est sûr que non imaginez ça de
même un plus ça va plus ça avance mais
ton le dans sa présidence puis dans plus
je le déteste
puis plus les gens qui le bac
encore ici au québec j'ai envie qu'ils
se désabonnent de tout méchant gens qui
arrêtent de carhaix je veux plus en voir
un clip je peux avoir un christ c'est
même plus un c'est mon run sur 35
ça me des calices de le voir ce style
c'est vrai c'est même plus politique
tu peux aller pour ses politiques
d'immigration tu peux être peut être à
droite peut être je mens collis c'est la
perf au king personne c'est un leader
misérables et divise les gens au lieu
des 10 fier une nation il est la pire
personne pour diriger le pays le plus
puissant au monde
ça me donne envie de vomir de voir qu'il
ya des gens qui votent pour lui
ça me des colis puissiez du monde au
québec parce qu'au québec on a quand
même une source d'information
somme toute pas biaisé par rapport à 3
le teaser aux etats-unis' t'écoute cnn
oui toutes les toutes les chroniqueurs
avons parlé contre m sauf que ici on a
quand même tout prix même si tu fais
juste regarder son pote une fille doit
être tu sais que c'est pas le leader
d'une nation ce que l'homme fait chier
les gens qui le bac me des calices ça
n'a rien à voir la politique tu peux pas
bac est une personne qui divisent comme
lui impossible puis je lui offrirai même
si vous
venir ici je dirais bosch yémen va chier
écris-moi plus jamais de la pire
personnes qui partageaient ce dernier
qui avait twitté déjà avec la stratégie
d'eads et d'airbus dans le fond c'est
ouais au discrédit des drames c'est
juste de laisser parler ce n'est pas
factice et même pas de même une
information biaisée t'écoute récent
rally piston est moindrement d'esprit
critique du changement tu voulais que ça
marche plus exact l'exact même pis c'est
ce qui me des choristes le plus semaine
parce que il ya plein de monde qui vont
s'arrêter à dire maintenant mais le hic
ce qui fait maintenant mettons du membre
du monde qui agresse pas raciste mais
plus conservateurs qui disent non mais
moi de son ca politique d'immigration je
suis quand même d'accord puisqu'ils est
fait avec le marché boursier de ces
chutes là je mens calice de ces
informations le jeu mais encore lisse
c'est pas souri si c'est pas lui qui est
à part des républicains
ça va être quelqu'un d'eau et même les
républicains mais là même le piano qui
spéculent trop républicain qui bat les
républicains depuis le début même eux
sont en train de faire un mais n'a aucun
sens le monde meurent par milliers à
chaque jour des prières de m culotte
pour fermer le christ deux pays
pis tu fais juste d'appliquer vite je
trouve ça débile entre que ça c'est mon
job fait que la réponse est non
vainqueur serait pas ici même la honte
qui restent les mêmes le monde
les républicains qui reste au sein de
son équipe c'est pour essayer fromage
control tb essayé de tempérer et
d'amoindrir de ses caves qui sait si ces
décisions de mort parce que si tu aimes
sa politique
l'autre personne qui va le remplacer
chez les républicains il va avoir les
mêmes politiques s'ils vont les mêmes
politiques surtout va prendre les est-il
dangereux comme la cave il sérieusement
mènent les états unis stosic haut en ce
moment pour celui du monde qui meurent
par milliers à tout l'effort king jours
puis mpaka de dire que c'est vrai
non ya pire ailleurs
le graphique encore le cpie même de
gullfaks c graphique n'est pas vrai
c'est débile mais parce que mon bâton
pour toi revenez la question moi je mets
moi je me suis déjà demandé m comment je
réagirais si je voyais ma temps qu'il y
avait des propos et oui qui étaient dits
durs un pote qui évoque à ce qu'on
produit c'est que nous on n'est pas là
mais ton oui parce que parce que c'est
déjà arrivé mais tant que je n'ai pas
d'accord avec quelque chose qui est dit
le mais c est nous mettons la limite
quand ça devient inacceptable qui
j'aurai tu te voir moi mais tu fais
l'acquisition la maison c'est quelque
chose que tu sais pas qui était pas sûr
mais nous le dit voir les autres on a
définitivement une responsabilité en
étant en étant les proprios du studio on
à responsabilité à qui on veut offrir
une tribune à qui on veut pas offrir une
tribune puis qui on veut qu'il y ait
quelques propos on veut qu'ils soient
tenus à l'intérieur ici on a on fait pas
de la censure mais c'est amener on a
l'impression que c'est pas quelque chose
qu'on compte qu'on accepte c'est sûr que
s'il ya quelque chose qui donne
maintenant dit
c'est dans une certaine limite le tir je
dirais qui tu préfères podcast ici pitt
y avoir des produits avant des pignons à
cliquer pas d'accord je peux dire et on
conserve au podcast mes petits jeux des
îles aux jo il n'y a pas de casque était
fait ci ou est ce qu'il ya un évident à
éviter quand même qu'une opinion
scientifiquement divergents du consensus
mais ton c'est quoi je pense que je
voudrais pas c'est quoi
pitié du monde qui veulent envoyer what
the fuck les gens ça s'est fait dans vos
studios pis j'étais quand même un peu
gênante pitt et ses poses pas seul à
savoir c'était pas vraiment qu'on
connaît bien le sujet
quand tu connais bien sujet tu sait que
le gorille disent n'importe quoi on ne
sort pas on sent malheureux mais mais
c'est ce obtient par le gie répondu oh
je répondais au monde titrait je peux
pas vérifier tout ce qui se dit dans les
lieux ici demont qui loue le studio mais
mais il ya quelque chose qui ne s'est
pas sous son toit fluide nous dira
legerweb de focus on voit chuter
excusez moi pour mon nom parce que comme
c'est le sujet moi mettons là j'ai été
capitaine du rouget rôti quand je
faisais de la rotation pis j'ai un peu
attristé quoi de de l'idée des gentils
c'est quoi un leader positif je l' ai
appris des fois je n'ai pas tout le
temps positif mais je l'aï appris sultan
puis de diviser comme ce même méthode
même george deubeuliou bush quitte qui
était vraiment polarisant comme figure
le au moins son objectif ce n'est pas de
diviser le peuple qui gouvernait c'était
de rallier tout le monde a une cause est
ce que la cause est un noble est ce que
la cause était tsk en guerre ces tests
et noble à ce moment là non pas pantoute
sur le point ici
sauf que au moins tout le monde était il
voulait ramener tout le monde par cette
cause là l'autre chomsky fait c'est
qu'il veut absolument monter une partie
des américains contre une autre partie
des américains
ça ça me des colis diviser pour mieux
régner
ben oui sauf que ce sont bêtes de son
pari mais tu vois si sobegi d'accord
avec toi non le retrait vrai pôle ne
devrait pas la parole à quelqu'un qu'on
aime qui dépasse certaines limites on
earth ou du monde avec lesquels on n'est
pas content des désaccords meetic on est
capables de se parler et puis quand on
est 80 on est on est on est d'accord sur
rien à faire en france a raconté par là
mais quelqu'un comme ceux de cépie ces
jeux je me pose des questions en termes
année maman je pensais en effet tu mets
ton richard martineau
alors on pourrait recevoir jean
martineau opi avons un dialogue avec
l'upc de trouver des terrains d'entente
possible voire 6 6 points comprendre si
on veut pas non plus et dalet bull puis
tout le temps en temps des même affaire
puis l'heure ainsi andré récemment je le
vois maintenant sur facebook puis sur
twitter tout ce qui fait c'est même pas
de l'opinion c'est des attaques
personnelles c'est comme quelqu'un écrit
quelque chose quelqu'un écrit quelque
chose puis il faut faire un screenshot
puis vous dire mais c'est ce titre fort
avec ce puits le monde
ils vont ils vont écrire genre ouais
c'est vrai qu'une fois le puits le monde
à écrire cette personne aurait été
vraiment une fois la nana semaine si ces
mêmes pays de l'union mais cela aurait
dans midi pendant longtemps je me suis
dit dans la ville du monde à droite et à
gauche piscicole et sommes sûrs qu'il
commence sa carrière comme artiste et
justin krueger de droite l'été mais
maintenant c'est passé si quelqu'un ya
plus d'argent aimer dieu puisque c'est
le clic bay qui commençait à l'emporter
mais lui pour se créer sa propre job on
y fait du clic certaine époque les
n'était même pas à droite limité
ouvrabilité est à la limite de la gauche
le 6 mai pour moi quelqu'un quelqu'un
qui est à droite victime elle même qui
même qui est contre plus d'immigration
tout ça fend d'un mec avec lesquels je
suis en désaccord sur des bons arguments
parce qu'ils défendent une façon de
parler
c'est par l'epeat il ya des arguments
solides et toujours respectueux on est
obligé tout est d'accord c'est correct
mais quelqu'un qu'il y aura qui a
recours à des attaques personnelles puis
à des insultes pour s'exprimer puis de
notre homme fait sûr de notre ami le
nombre de tweets condrey que sa maman de
l'enfant de 8 ans qui a écrit ja et à
puce 15 mars heureusement la pupille est
pas belle this également sur ses tweets
cc6 dégradant ses 6 ans d'école si c'est
vraiment ça n'a pas de sens c'est fait
pour quelqu'un qui ou si beau dans son
argumentaire ne peut pas déléguer que
c'est pas mal non
je dois retourner ext est-ce que de
planter célibataire asking for
de bonnes fêtes keven c'est pas toi mais
on dirait que 80 entretiens l'espèce de
flou entretient le flou de matérieux
accusations
ben je laisse un peu un dock le quai que
je posais gars sont là mais oui je fais
que ce qui pose une question de
l'hebdomaire au moins recevoir un
message personne peut écouter le podcast
avidement en attendant cette réponse la
bonne fête caven qui s'appelle qu'elle
s'appelle ou qu'il s'appelle encore sur
youtube c'est un compte
il reste près de questions le proche et
le tad way apple tv ou trois élus dans
ce qui reste et sel le sel est un peu
bad à répondre non non ce le bouffe
c'est le peu qu'on veut censurer
quiconque le sait juste qu'on veut
choisir la meilleure je laime ok si on
avait ramené une seule personne dans ce
sens avoir une relation sexuelle non je
pense aussi que faisait peut-être que ce
qu'ils ont mais bonjour à tous les
différends à gibbs
si on avait à ramener un monde à sur la
terre qui passe c'est ça qui est beau et
sympa mais je pense que l'on est parfait
quelle personne décédée est ce qu'on
voudrait ramener sur la planète
mettons dans son poids ils l'ont ramené
une personne qui dans son dans son apex
dans son apogée de 2 peu importe son
milieu où que ce soit on a une personne
en 2020 qui est au sommet de son art moi
je ramènerai genre mozart j'aimerais
c'est que mozart y arrive pile et entend
c'est quoi la musique qui se fait
aujourd'hui
mais qu'est ce qu'ils voient fax
genre un génie musical à ce point d'être
le plus grand génie musical que jamais
vu la tchéquie jamais menée qui écoute
qui écoute en ce moment ce qui se joue
qu'est-ce qui lé mai fais ce qu'il va
faire votre débit 'je sais qui va
sûrement faire de la musique
contemporaine mais sûrement par la
musique comme bien comme il y en a
maintenant
ben oui parce que lui visait la musique
qui crée dans le temps c'était la
musique et je le dis mais dont je te dis
mettons major sur une échelle de 1 à 10
de génie musical mesure ces 10 cas nier
ou au bain c'est vraiment dur à dire non
mais mettons après tout c'est comme ça y
est tu dis non non non non pas de basket
dans son style mais c'est qui qui est
neuf en ce moment c'est parce que moi je
peux pas croire que mon sort et forking
disque qui a plus jamais eu après ce
rapport les pros classé grand bain ça
dépend aussi ctc sur des neuf qui font
de la musique qu'on écoute t qui jouait
radio célèbre à ses côtés critères s'est
passé c'est quoi ton avec coach je
t'aime et on s'est vraiment déjà des
styles des talents différents think and
his et tim howes or là il y avait sept
ans qui y est allé mais parce que des
prodiges
ils vont toujours en avoir des émeutes
ont des gens qui aillent en cinq ans un
stylo comme si on avait su on aurait
peine vidéo youtube de section leur est
absolu qui passe à l'histoire avec toi
mais juste mettons pour comprendre
l'étendue du talent de mozart au vatican
qu'il y avait une pièce qui était joué
une fois par année
c'est comme une messe spéciale une fois
par année et les partitions était
secrète l'égard des genres dans un
cachot le trait personnes avaient accès
ses partitions de parce qu'il ya deux
jours c'est de jouer une fois par année
au vatican
et c'est des pièces orchestrales le
facteur
trente personnes qui jouent en même
temps de payer des chorales peut-être
lui vola avec son pareil c'est en une
seule écoute parce qu'il joue la pièce
une fois arrivés chez eux
l'écrit le traître est transcrit s'en
souvenait au complet note par note
instrument par instrument et leur
transcrit genre le vatican est en fait
déjà parce que maintenant je comprends
c'est impressionnant mais c'est un
talent un talent par lifetime le tout ça
existe pas d ttc comme ces mecs très
beau mais celui-ci indices tai chi et 1
heure puis c'est sûr que de 9 à notre
tourisme en plus qui ont existé même
genre non plus alors mais quand il
aimait tant qu' il produit la musique
mozart et après d'une part parce qu'il
faut qu'il faut que tu aies table et ce
avec les autres personnes qui le font
west ham et on sait pas ce que c'est sûr
que tout le monde qui ont un talent
extrêmement aigu comme ça le fond
métiers des mets ton décès c'est comme
tu dis des prodiges d'aider des jeunes
le tiki à la plainte et nos plaintes et
jacques l'oreille absolue
mettons qu'on mette en continu tu
balises de vetting et sur le fait sur
comment tu vas marquer mettons la
musique puis l'histoire des musiques et
en bas je dirais qu'à nier peut-être
huit succès tient neuf en ce moment dit
peter cech est ok je crois effectivement
way note 6 mètres mais muette c'est ce
tweet ouais si après c'est allé vite
impossible de comparer montanier sait
même pas le nom mais comme thomas levet
qui disait dit c'est possible car brahim
de comparer une pomme un an
c'est non mais je veux dire c'est
possible les deux sont des fruits puis
lequel est meilleur que l'autre
ça n'est pas des goûts mais après sur
lequel et ses ex davos est possible de
faire ça mais je suis là la question est
bonne de penser à acheter des génies
maintenant la question c'est qui on
ramènerait sa attends moi en ce moment
au québec
j'aimerais ça que qu'on a et rené
lévesque qui soit charismatique comme il
était puis qui donne envie aux québécois
de s'impliquer pour frais modiques ce
crime on dirait que moi c'est ce que je
veux je voudrais que je voudrais ramener
rené lévesque pour qu'on puisse se
placer derrière quelqu'un que du
charisme qui donnera envie de suivre
quelque chose oui
suivent un objectif c'est vrai qu'on est
plus y'a pus seuil à vie en lui on n'est
plus comme avant
y'a pus seuil a pu été jetés dans notre
premier ministre et je le suivrai pas
jusqu'à gare il dirait on s'en va à
gages
4 mais c'est ça le moins épais que
j'exerce une mesure donne envie de le
suivre comme comme en 2012 moustier je
voudrais en 2012
pendant la grève étudiante et gab bien
les ovules léo bureau-blouin c'était des
figures que je me dis tabarnak les
autres on les cite drive
il me donne envie de sortir dans la rue
c'est est-il et puis mon avis des
sourires moitié légaux et john malkovich
liquide puis good job le triste un bon
premier mineur sauf que tabarnak donne
pas envie de le suivre 0 charisme donne
pas envie de m'investir mince non pas
faire aussi
sauf que même au delà des au delà des
idées politiques t moi j'ai envie
d'avoir un leader charismatique
on a parlé du cas quelqu'un qui donne
envie de graviter autour quelqu'un qui
donne envie de s'impliquer pour quelque
chose qui prend ce qui ressemble à un
peu plus de sites côtiers madness
je reviens un peu au débat maintenant
avec catherine dorion techint cantat
un été je pense en coton ouaté je pense
à l'assemblée nationale quelque chose
même si c'est que c'est que ce serait un
symbole c'est juste se rapprocher un peu
plus du jardin des cotons ouatés mot
cibles exactes et mais c'est puis je
pense pas que seif c'est pas ça
maintenant qu'il fait d'elle mettons une
grande liberté
mais ce cd afin d'en moyenne et il faut
j'ai l'impression qu'on vote pour du
monde qui sont tellement loin de nous
qui en finale on vote pour des pénis tic
par l'axé comme j'ai envie tabarnak de
suisse a grelotté que moi maintenant un
mot quelqu'un j'écoute des vidéos de
kafala rdo gens s'aiment
moi ça me plaît qui craint que malade
mais c'est son métier c'est ce genre des
personnalités là qu'on a besoin et je
pense un des ses galettes il faisait
super détestée aussi ses élites
tu regardes des entrevues de lui se
faisait ramasser son entrepôt l'arcal
moi et m'a tout le monde en parle s'il
se faisait ramasser mais si il reste
avec son opinion et puis la chine puis
l'a10 et puis ça fait ça fait du sens
puis au final c'est ça qui donne son
charisme vous citez moi je pense que
c'est ce genre de personnalité le je
pense qu'ils qui manque le plus je sais
pas c'est aussi avec les racistes tout
genre mettant voir maintenant martin
luther king voir ce qui se promènent un
qu'est ce qui freine je sais pas été
juste de voir qu'est ce qu'il fait sinon
je vais charger complètement puis kobe
mobile
ouais mais j'aimerais ce genre plein
jésus-christ j'aimerais sur le ramener
le sport comme à son pic
ouais tu ramènes combien son pipeline en
nba puisque s'y fait audrey hendrix
était comme y arriver au point bon qui a
pris sa retraite il a commencé à faire
commence à faire des affaires il faisait
toujours plein de
degrandi bonne chose puis les a commencé
puis le tao quand j'ai reçu ce mois-ci
c'est cette année une nouvelle marche et
qu'ils aillent
mais je rappelle j'ai reçu une situation
j'ai regardé j'ai citées chez nous j'ai
fait
kobe bryant particulier que je sais que
j'ai chargé encore le nombre de sujets
beaucoup plus réclame est impliqué dans
le temps plus en ce moment
l'étude en question a fait le tour je
pense qu'on a posé beaucoup de questions
à poser votre question
c'était vraiment le fun est ce qui est
quelqu'un que j'osais je devais avoir
que très heureux que vous fassiez partie
de la vente sur les deux sites ou non
d'être là aussi tous nos pieds merci de
1,2 à de bons podcast kg une question
est une question pour finir sur une note
mitigée les taux locaux et l'eau l'avion
de type de film pente
non et pour finir son autorité à succès
et tout matériel
d'abord fine c'est un menteur il y avait
une question je la trouve plus deux mais
je l'avais lu tantôt le freestyle est ce
que tu suces quand on a mis de limites
pour werner les questions après une
soirée arrosée mais non mais y avait
demandé c'est quoi la plus belle qualité
chez mettons moi que je trouve chez toi
oui toi j'aime chez toi
stay tune je ne modifie pas ton opinion
pour plaire aux gens ça c'est vrai ça
fait longtemps que le remarquer en fait
vraiment longtemps depuis qu'on est con
ce qu'on veut qu'on se connaît ou du
moins qui est qu'on est capable
d'analyser ce genre de choses là mais tu
modifies pas ton opinion pour plaire aux
gens moi j'ai tendance à percer mais
tant qu'un que qu'un qu' il ya eu une
conversation pic et pic ça me tente pas
nécessairement l'aller l'homme je veux
juste plier mon opinion parce que juste
je tiens pas tant que ça mais tout de
suite tient quand même s'il ya des
opinions vêtus les touts les maintient
dans pas mal toutes les interrogations
c'est une question que j'avais lu aussi
aujourd'hui c'est sos qui est des
invités avec lesquels j'étais pas
d'accord puis vous l'avez pas dit oui
puis je pense qu'on le voit bien quand
ça arrive que moi je le fais depuis que
toi tu le fais pas je trouve que c'est
une qualité que ce soit je le fais parce
que je le fais pour soi jusqu'à se jeter
mon but
où se cache sans que ça vaut pas la
peine beh je parle pas mais je pense à
majorité des gens c'est comme ça c'est
juste que tu dirais que l'excès couche
le day2 marjet enlève le relais pour
voter pour te déguiser le stimule
tu es mon fils je fais tout le temps le
matin le temps aux gens avec qui je suis
bi lie avec certaines personnes que je
me sens ultra bien fait que j'ai pas
besoin de s'aimer des guitares est dans
une espèce de foie de porc réseautage
peu importe le tueur a ajouté deux
cochons dans un concept dans un contexte
de podcasts pour éviter qu'un invité
qu'il une fois c'est sarens commençait
argumenté
c'est déjà arrivé d argumentation
mais je devais arriver des moments où
est-ce que c'est clair qu aimer ton si
j'arrivais et y mettons que ma vision
des sauces et des sujets qui les ont
invités sont diamétralement opposées 1
mais pour moi c'est pas une raison je
vois quand même respecter la personne sa
vie je veux dire c'est quelqu'un que
j'ai avec qui je peux dialoguer quand
même t on et pau nos opinions négatives
des différents mois puis je te respecte
quand même fait que je peux dialoguer
touati puis il ya plein de fois où est
ce qui est clairement il y avait des
désaccords mais ça n'a jamais ça jamais
levé le ton parce qu'ils ne l'ont jamais
dire jamais de temps pas de casque parce
qu'il ya une fois au début où ça tourne
en rond va mal c'est quand on se
rappelle lequel il ya une fois ce que ça
tourne en rond mais après ce stage de
six enfants tête puis c'était juste
discussions dont l'argument arkema
arguments hakim arguments
ph et élèves pour je peux pas un patron
d'alex dupont mais c'était juste
arguments puis discussion tout le monde
était calme et à la fin c'est juste cool
je comprends ce que tu dis je comprends
je comprends ce que je dis depuis
quelque temps encore je sais fait très
longtemps
ça fait trop longtemps dans les 60 et au
début
lui comme un rappel au début j'étais au
camas est aussi pis c'était juste je
t'ai pas une argumentation qui veulent
être un rôle non non je les jeunes
reconnaît aujourd'hui que c'était pour
statut ping pong mais c'était beaucoup
de personnes qui écoutent boxe boxe etc
ou de peau qui qui qui se parlent mais
que ses coups de patte
on y plaide le brick lane lambert graves
sont dits pour la se sont donc mal que
même moi je me rappelle d'un podcast je
sais qu'à un moment donné ça va mal vous
piller vote un v6 vous n'arriviez pas à
même conclusion ses pieds vous avez
jusqu'à fait une coupure connais tu sais
quoi ma qualité tout à qualité c'est
c'est probablement aussi dans certains
cas ton des fonds mais cc7 à riga c'est
un détecteur de tout et est efficace et
travaillante et rigoureux ttt sacoche
c'est pourquoi ce sont des faux aussi
parce que des fois ça peut être chiante
une rigueur mais je comprends bien la
rigueur devient et intransigeance le des
fois ça peut devenir pendant ces dix
seuls en génération coop surtout
principal main répond à des questions
mais moi j'ai une qualité pour vous 2 kg
sorti de kallf on le savait l'école
prépare c'est juste que ces cas je sais
pas j'étais pas là souvent j'ai acheté
là peut-être cinq six invités peut être
mais où moi quand j'arrivais à mama mon
entrevue ne quittait plus une discussion
c'est quand je parle à mon grand frère
si je sais pas mais c'est ce en fait
c'est que dès que quelqu'un rantissi
s'est dit à l'aise à 100% que ce soit je
suppose c'est la combinaison des deux ce
soir plus que l'eau de c'est peu mais
dès que la personne est ici fac tantôt
ce que je disais avec les invités qui
sont moins à l'aise il y en a tellement
pas beaucoup plus même quand son prize y
arrive a parlé pendant une heure et
demie au moins deux tireurs qui soit
ultra light pour geoffroy
ok c'est bon je comprends réputé
personne fait ses dents ici des ya plein
parce qu'à ce qu'ils sont un peu comme
se le dise et fakir pas que proposez
vous pour ce sékou cissé l'ambiance que
ce soit
pour personne je pense que c'est
principalement s'aimer nom propre soit
vous pour ces iem
merci c'est gentil je pense que met-on
objectivement je pense qu'on a une bonne
écoute tu la sens que le podcast sans
fil podcast pour le show le plus
flamboyant ou genre sacré où on rit aux
éclats ou est-ce que ça explose t mais
on met une ambiance je pense qui fait
que je te ment continûment
sainte-thérèse pis on leur laisse
l'espace pour s'exprimer on leur pose
des questions pertinentes et puis je
pense tout à qualité oui toi tu es
d'erreur perfectionniste quand même je
pense bien faire un bon travail
si tu fais tes cachets avec vous fêtez
la recherche ou non mais tu sais si tu
sais ça comme php rigoureux été constant
titi en bleu ça peut être une qualité
c'est pas une qualité ou un défaut est
vraiment or je pense pas que le texte
voté date mieux de centre mais je pense
pas que tu sais qu est ce que tu vaux
beau vrai c'est vrai ce n'est pas vrai
parce que je pense pas que peut-être que
tu te laisses pas fait assez de temps
dans un autre job peut-être que mes mais
je pense pour que je sais comment
chanter pic est ce que ça vaut ce merci
puis voté bon tu es capable
nicolas un cercle avec toi
après deux heures c'est quelqu'un qui se
croit sincère mais nicole moi je vois
pourquoi on apprécie aussi sur c'est
quoi ta qualité c'est que tu es
extrêmement impliqué dans les choses que
tu fais puis mettons ici le au studio
des point d'employer les étés
décaissement propriétaire j'ai tellement
tellement tu es impliqué dans le truc
puis commence tu te s'obtient à carreaux
pis d'être impliqué dans les projets
dans lesquels sur lesquels je travaille
c'est tellement important mais c'est
quelque chose que qui va te servir
crissement et dans la job qui te
présentement ici et éventuellement
propos simplement dans d'autres jobs
dans d'autres projets dans d'autres
trucs créatifs de t'impliquer montgueux
dans tes trucs c'est capital puis tu le
fais chrisman merci c'est good
mais c'est ce tissu le projet de cirque
heures comme si qu'il avait fondé puis
ce qui ôte c'est que on peut on peut
compter sur toi pitié on construit
quelque chose ensemble plutôt que tu
viens du punch fait ezzor puis tout en
vociférant memmie bosman à orthez s'est
passé vraiment pas c'est vrai mais ce
continent non merci merci pour les bons
mots pour vrai pire d'enfants il
réajuste mois des poubelles etc semaine
on peut rater ça serait de l'unc non
bâti moi je me rappelle ma temps d'un
moment très précis qui me dit mais reste
en tête ou dans mes débuts en fait
c'était pas de casse avec rachid ait
fait ça faisait pas si longtemps que
c'est bon pas de casse à ce jour c'est
le plus long parce qu'à ce qu'on a fait
moi si tu me mets ce qui ce qui m'a
vraiment marqué des points ce qui m'a
marqué ce qui ce qui m'a vraiment fait
plaisir et on attend d'eux
c'est sa geôle voilà 2 3 ce que je
voulais dire j'ai perdu parce que je me
cherchais de rachat de matières non mais
tu mets ton j'arrivais d'un job ou ce
que je travaillais dans une piscine
fakty moi je faisais l'entretien y avait
plein de sauveteurs on était comme trois
grands entretiens fait qu'on était un
peu importe si j'arrivais mathon plossu
partager vos studios play y avait comme
rachid badouri rachid badouri qui rentre
dans le studio puis vous me parliez
autant à lui qu'à moi en fait c'était
vraiment et vous voyez en fait deux
êtres humains et et puis moi j'ai
tellement trouvé son oeil sur j'ai
tellement trouvé ça cool comme comme
attitude et je me sentais vraiment il
faut l'impliquer l'atide en fait moi sur
sa move ça m'a vraiment vraiment fait
fait du bien c'est fait plaisir puis
après je suis d'accord avec vous on lui
fait quitter mepi rachid syntaxe et
s'intéresse à toi aussi mme s'en
remettra pas je me disais c'est lui qui
a voulu prendre une photo avec moi afin
qui s'est passé exactement mais c'est
proposer maintenant pour que je prenne
une photo avec lui non droit il y avait
été super ce match aussi mais j'avais
juste trouvé ça vraiment cool c'est que
c'est pas n'importe qui qui rend dans le
studio juge suit comme des chiens au
même niveau c'est dans ce sens que j'ai
pas accompli les mêmes affaires matichon
un être humain aussi peach yoshi
j'ai vu comme au même niveau que les
autres pitié mans m'a vraiment ça ça m'a
vraiment fait du bien c'est ici on évite
de monde ce que qui nous inspire qui ont
fait des choses qu'ils ont fait
chose qu'on respecte qu'on trouve qu'on
trouve belge on trouve pied sauf que je
pense que tout le monde a quelque chose
à apprendre quelque chose à nous
apprendre vite et tout le monde est pas
une personne pour moi qui est choquée
qu'un versement tant pis si justement le
remettons le conte comme youtube ci
mettant toute l'histoire de la vague de
dénonciations pseudo c'est la preuve que
beaucoup de monde connu qui ont du
pouvoir tous les choses ensemble qu'ils
utilisent à mauvais escient tee pee wee
t il faut se questionner sur le
phénomène de 10 dollar tree du monde et
puis justement pourquoi ces gens rayon
des pouvoirs ce qui est des fois il ya
des six meetings avant les épreuves
d'histoire le 2
ces deux jeunes filles tu aimais tant
que des rations par texto dessous
vraiment 3 mars n avaient qu avec des
mondes connus des demandes et des goûts
du web sopi ça vient du fait qu'on met
certaines personnes sur un piédestal
parce qu'ils sont connus puis moi je
pense pas qu'on devrait mettre déjà sur
un piédestal à cause qui sont connus à
costumes fait quoi que ce soit de ses
pieds je te met la personne qui vient
ici au début
au début c'est ce qu'on a parlé tantôt
c'était stressant premier podcast de
rencontrer du monde
mais tu te rends compte rapidement aussi
que c'est du monde normal c'est du monde
connu c'est du monde normal heureusement
comme d'autres c'est c'est juste que
d'autres qui font un job tonight public
mais genre quelqu'un qui est des
demandes qui font des diabétiques sauvy
vie qui comprennent la fac sont
exceptionnelles quand incroyable qui
sont pas connues guy ces gens lyon
crissement hotas non plus mon respect
fuck fax est sorti il faut faut arrêter
de loterie les livres les gens connus et
respectés comme tout le monde mais ils
n'ont pas plus de valeur que toi ou
kennedy et ben eager après après je sais
pas combien de temps 4 qui se creuse en
cercle d'ailleurs remercié tout le monde
qu'ils écoutent les sans fil de leurs
parents de 4 go 2 6 1
un prochain employés prochaine personne
qui possède mon employée d'une personne
qui intègre l'équipe s'assoit sur une
face rennes face au losc on est rendu là
dans ce cas le yassa frisbee fake merci
pour deux ans on est sur cette camelote
monte ou non on est sur notre sol
allemand
on est sur nous autres pièces merci sans
épisode 2 1 de son fils pas de casse on
aurait arrêté après le premier si vous
aurez pas être si vous aviez pas été là
non merci
bh merci merci bonjour merci à tous les
invités qui sont venus tous les ans il y
arrive t il répondait ça fait pas de cas
non plus fait grand merci à trinité
ouais
puis merci qui merci l'afp qu'elle
allait bien
c'est tellement la berceuse du store
merci exactement ouais ouais
faites-le on se rejoint au mérite
et encore jusqu'au pont jacques cartier